Ist ja Leute, was mich wundert.
Der Chat hat mich mal wieder überrascht gerade.
Ich bin eigentlich fest davon auf...
Ah, nee, na, nicht richtig.
Da wollte er nie, hätte es fast geschafft.
Ich bin eigentlich ganz fest davon ausgegangen,
wenn ich diesen Desktop so mache, wie er jetzt ist,
dass das garantiert irgendjemand im Chat triggert und er was dazu sagen muss.
Aber bis jetzt, bis jetzt wusste noch keiner was zu sagen.
Kann ich es wieder normal machen?
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Warum ist das denn ein Ayaya-Desktop?
Zweimal Firefox?
Achso, ja klar.
Das eine ist ja auch Firefox.
Das andere ist Mozilla Firefox.
Äh, eben hat jemand abonniert, ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Giyokon ist am Start.
Stufe 1, 8 Monate.
Huge Subscriber.
Irgendwie...
Stimmt meine Größe vom Browser nicht?
Egal, was auch immer.
Ähm, ich habe übrigens gar nichts wirklich großartiges, spezielles vor heute.
Ähm, nicht Christine.
Christine!
Da ist das eh zu viel.
Ähm, ich wollte eigentlich nur gucken, ob der Stream funktioniert.
Deswegen muss ich mir mal meine Stats einblenden.
Weil ich das sehe.
Habe ich euch schon die, die, die wirklich absolut Big-Brain-High-IQ-Lösung
von Unity Media, beziehungsweise, äh, Vodafone erzählt.
Ähm, woran es, woran es gelegen hat.
Merkt euch, merkt euch eure Fragen mal.
Weil ich sehe schon, es gibt wieder im Chat, äh, Zeug.
Ja, das, das werde ich, werde ich gleich beantworten, wenn ich nicht wieder den, den Chat refreshe.
Aus Versehen.
Wann kommt der Cute-Desktop-Hintergrund?
Äh, nachdem ich meine 20 Emote-Slots gefüllt habe.
Übrigens ist, ist, ist euch aufgefallen, dass die Channel-Points jetzt,
dass Cute-Chat da ist und nicht mal Channel-Points.
Sieht aus wie Node.js-Linux.
Ey, Node.js, ich habe mir das angeguckt, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich wollte es eigentlich in der VRM ausprobieren, geht nicht.
Aber allein schon, dass es ein Node.js, ein Linux auf Node.js-Basis gibt, ist schon mal,
äh, fragwürdig.
Äh, Umut, da sage ich, da kann ich gleich was zu sagen.
Ähm, also zumindest, was Unity Media gesagt hat, ist,
die haben nicht gesagt Keck-W, aber die hätten auch genauso gut Keck-W sagen können.
Das wäre eigentlich kein großer Unterschied.
Gut gemacht.
Unity Media, also Vodafone, weil Unity Media ist jetzt ja, ist ja,
die haben, die haben den Red Dot Design Award.
Was ist denn zum Geist der Red Dot Design, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Irgendwas, was wahrscheinlich, was sie, was sie, die wahrscheinlich selbst gesponsert haben oder so.
Bei Red Dot GmbH.
Warum?
Unity Media hat die, eine der
ekligsten Webseiten.
Von Internet, also von, von Provider.
Warum, warum gewinnen die bitteschön einen Design Award?
Gut, das ist wahrscheinlich so eine, so eine, so eine Selbstfeier-Veranstaltung.
Red Dot ist für mich immer noch was, was man auf seiner MP5 draufmacht.
Ähm, das ist wahrscheinlich so eine krasse Selbstfeier-Veranstaltung, wie auch irgendwelche, äh, Filmfestivals oder sonst was.
Wo es im Prinzip nicht darum geht, wirklich, äh, die Leute auszuzeichnen, die was herausragendes gemacht haben, sondern sich einfach nur selbst ein bisschen zu feiern.
Cotra, ja, das ist richtig, Cotra ist größer, größer Red Dot.
Boris hat Cute Points ausgegeben und Geocona auch.
Zumindest, also, äh, was, was sie erzählt haben.
Und zwar...
Ich wurde heute bei Mittagessen angerufen von einem von Unity Media.
Ähm, der, der sich, der sichtlich auf-, also, der hör-, hörbar aufgeregt war.
Ich dachte schon, äh, als erstes fragt er mich, ob ich, ob ich der Max von, von, äh, YouTube, Twitch oder sonst was bin.
Weil ich hab schon, der hat, der hat schon so angefangen.
Der war, der war übelst aufgeregt.
Hab ich gedacht, okay, was ist los?
Und dann meinte er so, sagen Sie mal.
Und da kam aber was ganz, was anderes am Endeffekt.
Also, nicht revealed mit L-Adresse und sowas.
Zumindest, er hat mich angerufen heute beim Mittagessen.
Das war eh laut, ich hab ihn eh schlecht verstanden.
So, und, ähm, dann, ich muss jetzt grad mal gucken, dass ich das richtig, richtig rekonstruiert kriege.
Weil das war echt, das war echt wirr.
Also, ich hab mich ja da gemeldet bei, bei Twitter auf, warte mal, haben wir, sind wir ja aufgeschlagen bei der Christine vom Vodafone Support.
Und, äh, für die, die nicht dabei waren, ich hab mich ja beschwert.
Das ist dann mein Tweet.
What?
Ah, hier.
Genau.
Ah, seid toll, aber bla, bla.
Kackt alle fünf Minuten ab und die Bandbreite bricht ein.
Genau das war das Problem, während ich am streamen war.
Und da hat sie dann gesagt, sie kümmern sich drum und heute, und heute hat einer angerufen.
So.
Die, die, die hat mir ja schon geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, meine Routerwerte sehen nicht gut aus.
Was auch immer Routerwerte sein sollen.
Und der Unity-Media.
Und der Unity-Media-Mann, das erste, was der mir heute erzählt hat, ist, es sieht Traffic aus dem WLAN.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, what?
Also erstens, was hat das mit dem Problem zu tun?
Und, und, und zweitens, ich verwende das WLAN überhaupt nicht.
Von der Connect-Box.
Hab ich, hab ich gesagt, ich verwende das WLAN überhaupt nicht.
Ähm, äh, und, und ich hab auch schon mal mit dem Support, Support telefoniert.
Das, das ausgeschaltet wird.
Weil, ich weiß, ich weiß nicht, ob euch das bekannt ist.
Wenn ihr Unity-Media-Kunde seid und nicht widersprochen habt, ist automatisch ein, ein öffentlicher Unity-Media-Hotspot auf eurem Router auf.
Wisst ihr das?
Der hat zwar keinen Zugriff auf euer, also sollte, sollte, sollte nicht.
Sollte keinen Zugriff auf euer internes Netz haben.
Aber Unity-Media hat so ein Ding.
Ups.
Ups, ich bin im falschen.
Hallo?
Ich bin, ich will ins andere Browser-Fenster.
Weil die haben sowas hier.
Äh, Hotspot, irgendwas, äh, genau.
Äh, die haben das hier.
Und, wie das funktioniert ist.
Die, ähm, benutzen einfach die Router, beziehungsweise ihre Connect-Boxen und was sie da nicht alles verteilt haben, bei den Kunden daheim.
Quasi als Hotspots.
Für ihr komisches Unity-Media, äh, Unity-Media oder Vodafone-Hotspot-Ding.
Also, wenn ihr das nicht, nicht angeschaltet habt und euch fragt, was dieser komische Unity-Media-Hotspot ist bei euch, wo man sich drauf connecten kann.
Dann ist das, das Ding von Unity-Media.
Und ich hatte mal mit denen schon vor einer Weile Kontakt und hab gesagt, hier, ich will den Kram nicht haben auf meinem Router, mach aus.
Und schalt generell komplett WLAN aus, juckt mich nicht, benutze ich eh nicht.
Und deswegen hat es mich heute echt gewundert, wo der Typ von Unity-Media erzählt hat, ähm, es wäre Traffic, es wäre Traffic aus meinem WLAN.
Und ich sagte, ich verwende das WLAN überhaupt nicht.
Und dann meinte er so, ja, könnte sein, dass sie da mal aus Versehen ein Gerät angemeldet haben.
Und ich so, okay, also, ich will es jetzt nicht ausschließen, aber ich melde selten aus Versehen Geräte, Geräte an, an irgendwelchen WLANs bei mir, wenn ich nicht weiß, was ich damit machen will.
Aber okay, könnte sein, könnte sein.
Und dann meinte er, hab ich gesagt, ich bin aber gerade gar nicht daheim.
Also, das, das verwendet gerade garantiert keiner.
Und dann, und dann bin ich irgendwie im Nachhinein drauf gekommen, was der mir eigentlich sagen wollte.
Er wollte mir nicht sagen, dass er Traffic im WLAN sieht, er wollte mir einfach nur sagen, dass er Traffic von zwei unterschiedlichen Ports sieht.
Nämlich Port 1 und Port 3, was auch passt, ähm, weil an Port 1 hängt meine FRITZ!Box für VoIP und an Port 3 hängt mein Router für internes Netzwerk.
Hatte aber mit der ganzen Geschichte eigentlich überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Er hat, er hat nur komisch angefangen mit WLAN.
Und dann meinte er, hab ich halt zu ihm noch gemeint, so, gesagt, ja, aber das ist doch eh egal.
Ist doch eh egal mit WLAN.
Erstens hab ich ja die Probleme von, ähm, warte mal.
Erstens hab ich ja die Probleme vom Desktop aus.
Der geht ja gar nicht über WLAN.
Und zweitens hab ich ja eh meine eigenen zwei Access Points.
Die überhaupt nichts von Unity Media verwenden.
So, egal, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Ich hab mit dem da irgendwie eine Viertelstunde rumtelefoniert.
Er hat mir versucht, Dinge zu erklären, warum das WLAN irgendwie dran schuld wäre.
Dass, äh, meine Connection zu Twitch so für den Arsch ist.
Was, was, was, ähm, der Schwachsinn ist.
Denn ihr Peering ist einfach kacke.
Oder ihre Routen sind kacke.
Oder sie haben zu wenig gebucht.
Oder, oder was auch immer, ja.
Das ist garantiert, also geh ich ganz stark davon aus.
Dass das keine Probleme sind zwischen mir und Unity Media.
Sondern bei Unity Media, auch nicht bei Unity Media im Backend.
Sondern bei Unity Media aus ihrem Netzwerk raus.
Wohin? Geh ich mal, geh ich einfach davon aus.
Beim Beweisen kann ich das Ganze natürlich nicht.
Äh, vermuten aus dem, was ich bisher auch mitgekriegt habe.
Wie gesagt, ich hab mal, ich hab meine Ausbildung ursprünglich bei einem Provider gemacht.
Ähm, das ist, das war zwar auch mehr Richtung Enterprise-Geschichten.
Aber da hast du halt auch oftmals das Problem, wenn, wenn du halt zu, zu schlechte Kontakte hattest zu anderen Netzwerkbetreibern.
Dann war halt deine Anbindung in manchen Netzen nicht gut.
Und das kann halt, das kann halt auch schon mal passieren.
So, zumindest ist die Lösungs, die Lösungsbeschreibung, die er mir geschickt hat.
Ich hab mir nicht das 1-Gigabit-Angebot geholt.
Ich kann mir das 1-Gigabit-Angebot wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht holen.
Also das da.
Kabel, Kabelmax, was ja für mich den optimalen Namen hat.
Weil ich hab noch, glaube ich, ein Jahr oder eineinhalb Jahre, äh, Mindestvertraglaufzeit.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das, äh, umstellen kann.
Zumal, zumal das ja auch weniger kostet, als das, was ich aktuell bezahle.
Ist aber egal.
Kann das sein, weil...
Kann, kann das sein, weil...
Weil Unity, weil die den Namen Unity Media loswerden wollen?
Ah.
Das, das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
Das werde ich machen.
Wobei.
Nicht, dass ich dann dreimal Power Upload bezahlen muss, da ich einen echten Dualstack kriege.
Ich bezahle ja schon doppelt für Power Upload.
Dann bezahle ich dreifach für Power Upload wahrscheinlich danach.
Zumindest, ich lese euch jetzt, ich lese, ich lese euch jetzt mal die Antwort des Technikers vor.
Wo, wo er analysiert hat, wo bei mir das Problem ist.
Wohlgemerkt, ich habe kein WLAN auf dem Unity Media Router überhaupt an.
Das hätte er sehen können.
Ich war mir da am Telefon nicht so ganz sicher.
Ähm.
Und mein WLAN, was über meine externen Access Points läuft, davon kriegt Unity Media überhaupt nichts mit.
Es sei denn, die scannen wie verrückt meine Umgebung und bei denen läuft lokal irgendwelche Logs voll oder so.
Aber das ist echt nicht mein Problem.
So, also, die professionelle Störungsanalyse des Unity Media Technikers ist folgende.
Also, nachdem ich ihm das, was ich euch erklärt habe, erklärt habe und noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ähm, ist, wohlgemerkt, ich verwende kein WLAN von Unity Media.
Muss ich dazu sagen.
So, also, die Problemanalyse ist, lieber Kunde, Unity Media ist jetzt wo davon?
Das ist schon mal gut, dass sie uns das mitteilen.
Willkommen bei uns.
Um Ihre Störung zu beheben, vergeben Sie bitte für das 2,4 Gigahertz.
So, also, die professionelle Störungsanalyse des Unity Media Technikers ist folgende.
Wir haben für das 2,4 Gigahertz Band und für das 5 Gigahertz Band unterschiedliche SSIDs, auch genannt Netzwerknamen.
Hilfe finden Sie hierzu in diesem PDF.
Testen Sie anschließend Ihre Verbindung erneut.
Also, Unity Media sagt, die Probleme, die ich habe beim Streamen, dass die Bandbreite zwischendurch einprägt und abkackt, ist, dass meine, nicht von Unity Media, meine eigenen Access Points,
eine SSID verwenden auf dem 2,4 Gigahertz Band und auf dem 5 Gigahertz Band.
Was natürlich vollkommener Schwachsinn ist.
Und hätte ich dem das nicht erzählt, hätte ich dem das nicht erzählt, hätte mir das auch nicht als Lösung vorgeschlagen.
Ich habe ihm das nur erzählt, weil der meinte so nach dem Motto, ja, okay, das liegt am WLAN, das liegt am WLAN von der Connect-Box.
Und die Connect-Box hätte ja immer quasi standardmäßig.
Ja.
Die SSID auf beiden, auf beiden WLAN, auf beiden Frequenzbereichen und ich soll das mal ändern.
Da meinte ich ja noch zu dem, okay, brauche ich nicht, weil, ich meine, ich habe es bei mir auch so eingestellt mit doppelten SSIDs, aber ich benutze nicht die Connect-Box.
Habe ich ihm erzählt.
Und im Nachhinein, als ich jetzt heimgekommen bin, hat sich sogar herausgestellt, ich hatte nie WLAN aktiviert.
Oh, ne.
Mein Stream buffert.
Leute, mein Stream buffert.
Geht wieder?
Wo wir gerade beim Thema Vodafone sind.
LOLW, Alter.
Oh, oh, es geht weiter, Leute.
Fuck.
Okay.
Ich habe die Bandbreite mal runtergestellt.
So, Leute, ich habe die Bandbreite mal runtergestellt.
Man weiß ja nie.
Vielleicht bringt das was.
Es geht wieder, oder?
Keck W.
Okay, es geht anscheinend wieder.
In welchem Anlass?
Auf der Klammer.
Okay.
Wo soll ich das denn wissen?
Wo soll ich das wissen,
wie mich Unity Media irgendwie routet?
Keine Ahnung.
Wir lassen den Stream mal ganz kurz
auf 2 Mbit.
Ich meine, 2 Mbit bringen uns zwar auch nichts,
wenn der Kram wieder komplett einbricht,
aber dann ist vielleicht
zwischendurch nicht so viele.
Ist noch Delay.
Den Delay haben wir.
Oh. Oh. Grip.
Oh je.
Serious Max sagt,
wenn du weiter zu einem V-Server streamst,
der dann weiter zu Twitch streamt,
sollte das als Workaround auch möglich sein.
Es kommt drauf an,
wie die Routen zu meinem V-Server sind.
Wenn die Route bei Unity Media zu meinem V-Server
gut ist, dann ist das eine Lösung.
Da könnte ich auch irgendein x-beliebiges VPN
oder sonst was verwenden mit einem anderen Ausgang.
Das würde funktionieren.
Weiß ich halt nicht. Müssen wir mal testen.
Der Delay ist höher.
Gott. Unity Media,
please, Alter.
7,1% ist doch lächerlich.
Was ist das hier?
Guck dir das mal an.
545 Kilobit.
Okay.
Ich geh mal auf Twitter.
Ich geh mal auf Twitter und mecker rum.
Äh, DomPC,
was meinst du mit siehst du?
Ich muss mal kurz den Chat refreshen.
Der Chat ist mal kurz weg.
Ich seh ihn jetzt kurz nicht.
Was meinst du denn mit hast du zu?
Wo soll ich das missen?
Autonom, das ist irgendeine BGP-Geschichte.
Die seh ich von mir aus doch nicht.
Okay.
Ich werde mal
auf Twitter rummeckern.
Bei Unity Media.
Wo hab ich denn hier meinen Tweet?
Ach ja, wollen wir mal testen?
Bei der Gelegenheit.
Ich könnte euch doch mal zeigen,
wie man zumindest testen kann,
ob es an einem selbst, also zumindest
bis zum Router testen kann,
ob es an einem selbst liegt
oder nicht.
Das kann ich euch nochmal zeigen.
Wir machen mal meine Linux-VM an.
Ich hab nämlich einen Raspberry unten stehen,
der die Verwaltung, das Unify und
und Gedöns für...
äh, Ubuntu ist weg.
Ich hab hier einen Raspberry unten stehen,
angebunden, der die Verwaltung macht für meinen
WLAN und Zeug und bisschen Kram draufläuft.
Und der geht halt,
der hört halt quasi,
ähm,
vor der Connect-Box auf.
So. Und das heißt, wir können jetzt mal
einen IP, einen IPerf,
oder ich sag immer IPperf, weil ich
Pepega bin, anschmeißen
auf, äh,
dem Raspberry.
PyAd. Ich hoffe, der ist das.
Oh ne, der ist das nicht. Okay.
PyAd.
Wer da? Ist es der vielleicht?
Ah, Pfeifad. Excellent.
Namenswahl. Excellent.
Exquisite.
So, so muss der Server heißen.
Nur so ist das richtig. Ah, yes.
Excellent, excellent.
So, namenswahl IPperf.
Und zwar, ich weiß aus dem Kopf
gar nicht, wie man das macht. Und da können wir jetzt
testen, wie gut
meine Verbindung quasi hier ist, von mir lokal,
äh, zu quasi nem
Raspberry Pi, der bei mir auch im Netzwerk steht,
quasi vor der Connect-Box.
Die Seite bestimmt anhand
deiner IP, in welchem ASN du bist. Ah, okay.
Äh, Dom-PC, ich hab den Chat-Refresh,
ich seh's nicht mehr. Du müsstest mir das grad nochmal
schicken.
Okay, ähm, sag mir
übrigens, wenn der Stream wieder abbricht, namenswahl.
So, also, äh, IPerf
Test. Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie man den Kram aus dem Kopf
macht. Das gucken wir einfach mal.
Gucken wir einfach mal, geil. Na, ich glaub,
IPerf-S war's, glaub ich.
Oh, muss ich erst mal installieren.
Okay.
IPerf 3.
Come on, bruh. The Hook!
Sechs Monate lang, schön.
So, probieren wir das Ganze mal aus.
Wir haben jetzt Glück, dass der Stream ganz gut läuft,
mit 2 Mbit, grade zumindest.
Weil, das halt statisch ist.
Was? Minus S?
Ah, okay, war anscheinend minus S. Sehr
excellent.
Äh, 1221 hat gesagt 111111.
So.
Ich würd sagen,
da ist alles okay. Ich mein, das ist ein Raspberry
3. Der ist jetzt an sich schon nicht
sooo der krasse Bringer.
Ja.
Aber ich würde doch, ich würde doch mal behaupten,
das sind mehr als 2 Mbit,
was da drüber geht.
Minimal. Minimal mehr.
Äh.
Der Martin abonniert Stufe 1
für 7 Monate, dankeschön.
Und Knär giftet
sap an Knär.
What the fuck, Alter?
Giftet sich irgendwie selbst 3 Monate.
Perfekt, dankeschön.
Ähm, ja.
Also das, ähm, ist vollkommen
im Rahmen.
Vollkommen im Rahmen. Da ist kein großartiger
Verlust oder sonst was. Also das
liegt nicht an uns.
Mit uns mein ich, also mir.
Ja. Achso, ja, und dann mach ich
das einfach im zweiten Browser auf
DOMPC. So.
Ähm. Ich.
Your ISP is
AS6830.
Liberty Global
BV steht da.
Sagt, sagt der das was? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Was uns das jetzt sagen soll,
weil ich kenne halt die netten.
Woher soll ich die kennen?
Xfatal1337, dankeschön.
Gut, also an uns liegt's nicht.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt mal wieder
äh, rüber zu Twitter gehen.
Bandbreite hat nichts damit
zu tun, ob du Paketverlust hast.
Ja, aber Retries haben was damit zu tun,
ob ich Paketverlust habe. Und außerdem,
ähm, wenn ich nach
Twitch hin schon mit
8 Mbit Probleme habe und das rumwackelt
und einbricht, und das Problem
auf meiner Seite liegen würde,
dann hätte ich garantiert keine
konstanten 284 Mbit
zu ner Kiste, die direkt vorm Router steht, ohne
Retries, oder ohne, quasi ohne Retries.
Also immer noch im Unity Media.
Okay, ist das schlecht?
Der Milchmann, 8 Monate, dankeschön.
Huge, huge sub.
Gut, ähm,
dann gehen wir jetzt mal auf
äh, dumm.
Und antworten mal Unity Media.
Auf welchen Tweet antworten wir denn jetzt da am besten?
Weil die haben, die,
die haben ja noch ein paar mal
was antworten wir denn?
Auf den, auf
den? Nee.
Handynummer ist raus, auf Handynummer ist raus antworte ich.
Geht mein Chat?
Äh, also mein Chat geht.
Ja, aber bei den Problemen ist das
schon ganz okay. Guck mal was, das waren hier teilweise
ich hatte
Zwischenzeit, vor allem das witzige ist ja, dass es jetzt
ja erst wieder seit 40 Minuten funktioniert.
7%
war weg.
Gut, die Pakete könnte ich tatsächlich ein bisschen
ein bisschen mehr reinschreiben.
Aber da, ich
muss das, ich muss das nicht weiter testen.
Das liegt garantiert nicht an mir.
Das liegt an der Verbindung von Unity Media zu Twitch.
Ähm,
sonst hätte ich auch bei anderen Sachen mehr Probleme,
sonst hätte ich auch Buffern bei, ähm,
sonst hätte ich
komische Dinger beim YouTube
Upload, der, den ich ja nicht mache.
Ähm, oder bei irgendwelchen anderen
Streams oder sowas. Das ist voll für'n Arsch.
Was kostet
dich die IPv4
Adresse?
4, äh, 2,99 glaube ich.
Ich hab Dual Stack. Ich hab richtig echten
Dual Stack.
Bezahle ich ja auch doppelt den Kram.
Also wie gesagt, die Begründung,
die Begründung des, ähm,
Vodafone Mitarbeiters war ja,
das WLAN ist schuld. Das war von Anfang
an ja schon ziemlich bescheuert.
Ähm,
aber jetzt, jetzt, jetzt hatten wir's wieder.
Ich stell mal, ich stell mal die Bandpreise hoch, was dann
passiert. Mal gucken.
Es läuft jetzt ja relativ stabil.
Ich mein, es ist, es ist,
es ist, hat wahrscheinlich nix damit zu tun.
Ich geh mal davon aus, wenn's gut funktioniert,
dann ist es auch egal, ob ich mit
2, 4 oder 8 streame, dann wird das
funktionieren, weil das waren ja zwischenzeitlich
komplette Einbrüche und Streamabbrüche von
10, 15 Sekunden. Äh, der
Stream läuft, das ist ne gute
Frage. Das, was ist
RTMP?
Das wird wahrscheinlich,
ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht,
äh, nee, nee, RTMP ist
glaube ich, ist, ist, ist glaube ich sogar
TCP. Ich bin mir da, müssen wir mal
gucken, ich bin mir da gar nicht sicher jetzt.
Gucken wir mal, was das ist.
Works on top on TCP port 1935.
RTMFP,
which is RTMP over
UDP.
Aber allein schon, dass ich
wenig Retransmits hab, deute darauf hin, dass
das nicht an mir liegt. Welche
Anbieter sind gut? Kommt auf deine Region an.
Äh, ganze Twitter
Spreien, dankeschön.
Aber wenn du willst, wir
können das auch nochmal mit UDP testen.
Das macht kein, macht, äh,
wahrscheinlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Machen wir das nochmal per UDP, da muss ich aber nachgucken,
wie man das, wie das ging. War das,
war das nicht einfach Minus, war das nicht Minus, Minus,
war das nicht einfach Minus U?
War das nicht einfach
Minus U? Nee.
Ach du Kerl.
Nee, äh, ich habe auch bei Twitch, ist
ja, ist, ist kein großes, ist kein großes
Buffer. Aber bei Ausfällen
immer wieder zwischendurch von 15 Sekunden,
da kommt kein Buffern hinterher.
So, äh,
wie ging das?
War doch Minus U, oder?
Ach so, ah, genau, man muss das am Server nicht angeben.
So war das.
Exquisite.
Ja, die 600 kann ich übrigens wegmachen, ja.
Hey Max, brauche dein
Rat. Hab heute mit meinem Arbeitskollegen
geredet, er sagt, dass
0 Watt sei völlig anonym. Das habe ich jetzt
schon öfters gehört. Habe ich,
habe ich noch nie, noch nie,
noch nie verwendet.
Wo ist denn die Verbindung,
so kack lahm, äh. Aber gut,
ich meine, ich, ich, ich loste nichts.
Ähm, bei UDP, äh, bei Dings, da muss
man irgendeine Rate einstellen, ne?
Da muss dann, bei UDP
Test muss man irgendeine Rate einstellen, bei
RPRF. Hier, genau.
Watt, wie ging das nochmal?
Ja, so.
Ein M, Minus B
ein M, genau. Minus B
ein M.
Also machen wir mal 100 M.
Guck, da ist nix.
Da ist,
es würde mich auch sehr wundern, wenn da
irgendwas wäre. Vor allem bei,
vor allem bei einem Frametrop von irgendwie 7%.
Oh!
Oh doch, 0,079.
Ähm, ich,
ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe mir die ganze, ich habe mir
Wullwatt noch nicht angeguckt. Ich habe das jetzt schon öfters gehört,
dass das irgendwie, äh, super toll
und, und, und anonym wäre, aber ich würde
wüsste nicht, warum das, warum das irgendwie
großartig anonymer sein sollte,
wie, wie andere
Dinger, ja. Ich habe ja da extra mal ein Video
zugemacht. Das kennst du wahrscheinlich,
oder? Das, äh,
irgendwie Lügen der
VPN-Anbieter, wie ist das?
Das kennst, das kennst du wahrscheinlich schon, gehe ich mal von
aus, ja. Ähm,
im Prinzip
hast du die gleichen, du hast bei allen
VPN-Anbietern mehr oder weniger die gleichen
Probleme. Erstens ist,
also erster Punkt ist, was
die, sagt mir übrigens, wenn der Stream laggt,
ähm, du hast keine Ahnung, ob
die das machen, was sie sagen.
Das ist ja schon mal, das ist ja schon mal der erste Punkt.
Also sprich, du kannst noch
so viele Dienste haben, die sagen, wir
loggen nicht mit, äh, wir geben
nichts raus, wir machen erst gar keine Aufzeichnung,
wir machen keine Analysen, wir, wir
schneiden nichts mit. Die können alle
viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ähm,
aber guck dir mal an, wie man da einen Account
erstellt, also mein Konto.
Geben sie ihre Kontonummer an.
Ist sehr anonym, wenn ich da meine Kontonummer
angeben muss.
Neues Konto anlegen.
Ah, ach so,
die Kontonummer. Nicht,
nicht, nicht die Money
Kontonummer. Ja, aber,
gut, ähm, ich, ich, ich hab,
ich kann's dir, ich kann's dir im Detail
nicht sagen, aber selbst das
hier macht's ja nicht anonym.
Fuck, Kontonummer
liegt, OMG.
Ähm, selbst das macht's ja
nicht anonym. Du musst ja von dir
zum VPN-Anbieter
und, ähm, du musst dich
da ja einwählen. Das heißt, der VPN-Anbieter
hat auf jeden Fall deine IP
ähm, zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo du dich verbindest.
Oder die ganze Zeit, wo die Verbindung,
hat er, geht ja nicht anders, ne?
Ähm,
und selbst wenn die jetzt sagen,
sie, sie, sie speichern nix und
ähm, sonst was,
das ist im Prinzip
nicht das Papierwert, worauf's geschrieben ist.
Das kann, das kann so sein,
muss es nicht, du kannst es weder kontrollieren,
noch, noch, äh, wirst du es je rauskriegen,
bis es mal irgendwann halt
hart auf hart
kommt, ja? Ähm,
was ist, wenn man VPN
über VPN macht? Dann hast
du prinzipiell das gleiche Problem, aber es wird natürlich
immer komplizierter, und da kommst du so
ein bisschen in die Region, was Tor macht.
Ich mein, Tor ist nicht wirklich VPN über
VPN, aber Tor ist quasi
irgendwo rein,
dann randomized zwischen unterschiedlichen
Knoten, die quasi
selbst, zumindest in der Theorie,
äh, nicht nachvollziehen
können, ähm, wo was
herkommt, wo was hingeht, und, und wo's dann,
was dann, wo's am Ende rauskommt.
Das, das ist ein ähnlicher
Gedanke dahinter, wie VPN über VPN
über VPN über VPN. Das ist zwar ganz,
vom Ansatz her ganz anders, ähm,
aber wer anonym sein
will, der macht nen Tor-Browser auf, allerdings
auch da, und das ist ja das, was ich, was,
wo ich mich auch hauptsächlich in dem anderen
Video ausgelassen hab, ist,
ähm, die meisten Leute,
die wollen ja
alltägliche Sachen machen,
im Internet, so. Und wenn du
alltägliche Sachen machst im Internet,
dann wirst du über kurz oder lang
Sachen leaken von dir,
ja, dann machst du irgendwelche DNS-Abfragen,
dann hast du vielleicht irgendwelche
Plaintext-Ads,
die nachgeladen werden mit irgendwelchen
Session-IDs, oder irgendwas,
ja, also sprich, wenn du normale
Dinger machst, läuft
genug Traffic da ab und zu mal drüber,
den man dir schon zuordnen kann.
Vielleicht nicht sofort, wenn man nur ein Paket
mitgeschnitten hat, aber wenn man das
wirklich ne Zeit lang beobachten würde,
kriegt man das raus. Genau.
Äh, Basti, das kann man auch machen,
allerdings, selbst
das ist, ist halt, ist, ist halt
die Frage,
du lässt es ja immer noch irgendwo anders laufen,
also, ich, ich finde es
generell relativ unsinnig.
Wenn man darauf bedacht ist,
dass sein Traffic verschlüsselt ist
zwischen Anbietern, die man, die man
verwendet, sagen wir mal den, den Mail-Anbieter,
oder irgendwas, dann macht man das Ganze über
HTTPS und gut ist,
da gibt's auch kein, keinen weiteren Zweck
für Anonymisierung. Einer der
wenigen Anwendungsfälle, wo ich sagen würde,
hey, das ist sinnvoll, oder kann
man machen, ist, wenn man viel irgendwie
in öffentlichen WLANs unterwegs ist.
Wenn man viel in öffentlichen WLANs unterwegs ist,
und, äh, quasi
das da irgendwie nicht verwenden will,
weil,
ist ja egal, gibt's, hat zumindest noch irgendwie
ne gewissen, gewisse Berechtigung,
dass man das sagt, ähm, dann
kann man nen VPN aufbauen, aber da muss man das auch nicht
zu irgendeinem VPN-Anbieter machen, oder zu irgendeinem
äh, Server, den man sich im Internet
gebietet hat, sondern am besten einfach zu sich
heim. So.
Dann hast du natürlich absolut nicht diesen
Anonymisierungsfaktor, den man sich von nem
anderen verspricht,
aber du hast, äh,
die Probleme nicht mehr, die du dort im öffentlichen WLAN
hast. Aber, wie gesagt, Anonymi-
äh, Anonymität über, über
VPN-Dienstleister,
also, es kommt
natürlich auch drauf an, was man macht.
Wenn, wenn, wenn die Leute
Dinger treiben wollen, wo sie halt im
Zweifelsfall für in den Knast kommen, gibt ja immer
Leute, die komische Dinger treiben,
ähm, oder auf gar keinen Fall wollen,
dass das mit ihnen in Verbindung gebracht wird,
dann musst du erstens sehr
umsichtig sein, was du so
machst, am besten eigener
Rechner, eigene VM,
zumindest mal eigene VM, für jegliche Sachen,
die man da macht, und den Tor-Browser
verwenden. Und
selbst dann ist es schwierig, guck mal,
es gibt so viele Sachen, die aufgeflogen
sind in der Vergangenheit,
teilweise durch abenteuerliche Geschichten,
äh, ich kann mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern,
was das für ein Anbieter war, irgendeine
Darknet-Geschichte war das, wo sie bei ihm
die Wohnung gestürmt haben,
und im Vorfeld
ihn quasi über irgendeinen Chat
so manipuliert haben, dass er nicht in
griffreich Weite zu seinem Notebook
war.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welcher Anbieter das war.
War das, nee, das war,
war das Silkroad? Ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab's mir nicht gemerkt, was das war.
Da war ein riesen, da war ein riesen
Akt dahinter, weil der Typ da war
definitiv nicht blöd.
Der Typ da war nicht blöd, der hat einen eigenen Notebook
verwendet, hat das nur über Tor- und
Anonymisierungsdienste gemacht, und trotzdem
sind sie ihm auf die Schliche gekommen, allerdings
nicht so hieb- und stichfest, dass
das Beweiskraft gehabt hätte.
Deswegen mussten sie sein Notebook erwischen,
und der Typ war natürlich auch clever,
vollverschlüsseltes Notebook
mit allem, und
wenn er das Ding zugeklappt hätte, oder
Stand-by,
Stand-by gefahren hätte,
ähm, dann
wäre das halt, hätte das Ganze halt nicht funktioniert.
Ja.
Tor ist, ja,
kompromittiert, das einzige, was ich verwenden würde,
ist tatsächlich Tor.
Wobei es da auch theoretische Angriffsszenarien gibt, aber
dadurch, dass sie ihn erwischt haben, war ja
unter anderem auch, weil sie
ihn angeschrieben haben,
quasi mit, mit, mit nem
jebaited quasi,
mit nem Typ, der ihm Dinge erzählt hat,
die ihn dann getriggert haben, Sachen zu machen
im RL.
So. Ich mein, sie hatten ihn wahrscheinlich
vorher schon ein bisschen in Vermutung,
und zwar müssen sie irgendwie da drauf gekommen sein, dass
der und so, ähm,
oder haben sie es wohl irgendwie so gedreht,
dass, äh,
ihr Kontaktmann, was auch immer,
ich weiß nicht mehr, was es für ein Anbieter war, ich hab da aber mal recht
ausführlichen Artikel so gelesen,
dass der ihn vorher im Chat angeschrieben hat,
und der quasi abgelenkt war durch,
weiß ich nicht, Telefon, irgendwas anderes,
und dass die quasi wie ein paar Schritte
weg war vom Notebook,
die, ähm,
die, ähm, Tür
eingerammt haben, reingestürmt sind,
und das Notebook gekrallt haben,
bevor das zuklappen konnte.
Äh, wenn, wenn man nen Tor-Note
von Behörden betrieben wird, und das der erste ist,
mit dem man reingeht, ist das schlecht. Das ist egal.
Man, man kann sich,
man sollte sich aussuchen,
was für ein Exit-Note und so, man fängt,
das ist von der Theorie her, ist das nicht so wichtig.
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn und Zweck, äh,
des Tors, dass, ähm,
du das nicht zuordnen kannst.
Es sei denn,
und das ist, das ist ja der, den Fail,
den viele Leute machen, ähm,
du machst da,
dann,
als, als Sachen drüber,
die dich, die dich irgendwie irgendwo
anders leakbar machen, ja,
das wird davon auch
nicht sicher, weil, wenn du Tor
verwendest, um auf irgendwelche Dienste
im Internet zuzugreifen,
dann muss ja dein, dann muss ja dein Traffic da irgendwann
wieder raus. Und,
wenn dein Traffic vorher nicht verschlüsselt
ist, ist er, nachdem er aus Tor rauskommt, auch nicht
mehr verschlüsselt. Was ja das gleiche,
was ja das gleiche Problem ist, wie bei einem
VPN. Also,
selbst wenn man mal sagen würde, der VPN
Anbieter ist der Beste und Tollste
auf der Welt, den es gibt, mach mal kurz die
Auflösung wieder ein bisschen hoch,
wieder auf, wieder auf die Normale,
äh, selbst wenn man jetzt sagen würde,
der VPN-Anbieter ist der Beste und
Tollste, den es gibt,
der macht nix und der macht auch wirklich nix,
für das, was da meistens
angepriesen wird, ist es halt trotzdem komplett sinnlos,
weil du willst ja zu irgendeinem Dienst hin
und wenn dann Zeug unverschlüsselt ist, oh, ich hab da grad
was gesehen, ach nee, das ist hier,
Frames insgesamt, ähm,
der Traffic muss ja aus dem VPN wieder raus.
Und danach, und danach ist das auch wieder entschlüsselt.
Also, mal ganz billig
gesagt, die primitivste Variante,
wenn du Pizza bestellst über Tor,
dann weiß der Lieferant nur
trotzdem, wo sie hinkommen müssen, wenn du nicht bezahlst.
Was hältst du von der
Krypto-AG? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was die Krypto-AG ist.
Ich halte aber generell von
keinen Anbietern was, die für mich
Kryptowährungen verwalten wollen.
Kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr noch, Moment,
Leute, kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr noch die hier?
Kennt ihr die noch?
Ja, das ist er.
Kennt ihr das noch?
Das war, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher,
ob ich es noch, ob ich es noch richtig zusammenkriege.
Das war ein Scam, also
eine Kryptowährung
Plattform,
ähm, wo man, wo man die,
ihr müsst, korrigiert mich, wenn ich
da falsch liege, klickt das immer richtig aus dem Kopf zusammen.
Ich glaube, das war eine Plattform, eine der vielen
Plattformen, die quasi Kryptowährungen
verwaltet hat für dich und versprochen
hat, sie machen aus, sie vermehren deine
Kryptowährung irgendwie nach so einer Art
Schneeballsystem war das doch.
Und, ähm,
oder waren die das?
Zumindest, das Ding hat
Kilometer, wir gucken einfach mal nach, wer das
jetzt gewesen ist, das Ding hat Kilomet,
nicht PodConnect, das hat Kilometerweise
nach
Scam gestunken, das Ding.
Und die Leute haben trotzdem
äh, den Scheiß
mitgemacht, ja.
Leute, ihr dürft nicht so schnell
im Chat schreiben, ich komm gar nicht hinterher, ich hab hier ganz viele
rote Nachrichten, ich kann gar nicht alles beantworten.
Äh, bitte, Open Source Cryptocurrency,
das was Connected,
Ponsi, Ponsi,
das ist ja im Prinzip so ein bisschen sowas wie Schneeballsystem.
So, das haben die, haben die
Leuten versprochen, da gibt's dann die Storys
davon, wo Leute ihr Haus verkauft haben und
Geld da reingesteckt haben und, und, und
Zeug, ja. Ähm, und
das war halt die, die Zeremonie,
die, quasi die,
die, die, ja, so
die Art Eröffnungszeremonie von BitConnect.
Und das Ding ist halt
über Nacht zum Meme geworden, weil das,
das, das riecht so nach Scam.
Die Leute sind trotzdem drauf reingefallen.
Wir gucken jetzt mal kurz die drei Minuten an.
Und danach müsst ihr mir sagen, habt ihr nicht das
Gefühl, dass es Scam ist?
Was ein Crap!
Vor allem die Leute da hinten so irgendwie,
Alter, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich hier eigentlich
mache.
Mein Ohr!
Würdet, würdet ihr nicht auch sofort euer Geld reininvestieren?
Gibts zu, oder?
Ist schon echt überzeugend.
Natürlich! Einfach so! Und
wo hat er das Geld her?
Weil ihm Leute im guten Glauben sein Geld gegeben
haben. Das ist so Scam!
Guckt ihn da hinten an! Die hat keinen blassen
Schimmer, um was es geht!
Nein, nein, nein, nein!
Das ist nicht möglich. Das kann kein Scam sein.
Ich mein, das kann kein Scam
sein, weil er sagt
ja, er ist kein Scam.
Das ist logisch. Scammer
würden nie behaupten, sie sind keine Scammer.
Guckt euch die mal an!
Also entweder wissen die es
genau, aber ich glaub eher, die stehen
da einfach so Statisten-mäßig hinten
rum und haben eigentlich keinen Plan, um was es geht.
Wie Connect!
Wie hält er das
mit?
Der ist schon, äh, äh,
also, der hat sich vorher auch gar nicht
reingeschmissen.
Connect!
Ja, für ihn
zum Geld verdienen!
Das ist...
Das ist so
Scammig!
Das ist doch
für'n Arsch!
So, Leute, und jetzt mal ehrlich.
Hättet ihr investiert?
Sofort, oder?
Sofort! Haus verkauft,
Auto verkauft,
Frau verkauft,
alles verkauft, nur für BitConnect!
Direkt, klar, war klar, ja.
Was sonst?
Wir hatten keine Frametrops mehr.
So, jetzt habt ihr auch mal BitConnect
gesehen.
So wichtige Sachen, kann ja nicht sein.
Die Bildungslücke
haben wir jetzt auch geschlossen.
Ähm, ja, eigentlich
wollte ich Unity Media flamen, beziehungsweise
Vodafone, dass der Stream wieder abkackt.
Aber ich warte
nochmal. Wir machen jetzt einfach weiter.
Und ich guck jetzt mal in den Chat
nach, was ich hier übersehen habe. Ganz viel
Zeug hab ich übersehen.
Genau, und wie gesagt, zu diesem, zu diesem
VPN-Dienst an sich,
ich hab mich auch ausprobiert, ich kann dazu nichts sagen.
Ich denke aber, dass er genauso sinn- oder unsinnig
ist, wie alle anderen VPN-Dienste auch.
Ähm,
Anon fragt, frage mich, ob es
möglich wäre,
ein System
zu bauen, wo der Anbieter
nicht nachvollziehen kann,
wer was schickt und
empfängt, beziehungsweise eine Blackbox
ist ähnlich einer
Nutbox auf Crack.
What? Achso,
ah.
Naja, doch, das ist
kein Problem. Du musst einfach
dein eigenes Netzwerk aufbauen.
Es ist ja prinzipiell
nicht nachvollziehbar.
Wenn du nen VPN mit nem,
wenn du nen VPN zu, zu,
keine Ahnung, nem Kollege zu dir
aufbaust, oder zu nem Freund zu dir aufbaust,
und ihr euch da Sachen drüber schickt,
das kann keiner nachvollziehen, was
ihr da drüber schickt.
Ich hab das jetzt gescheit aufgesetzt. Kann keiner nachvollziehen.
Das liegt aber auch da,
weil die Daten
quasi von der Quelle ans Ziel
laufen und da nix anderes mehr dazwischen ist.
Das muss nie public über das
Internet, was ja bei VPN-Diensten auch nicht der Fall ist.
Bei VPN-Diensten muss der Kram
ja erstmal zum VPN-Dienst,
also über den
VPN-Tool zum VPN-Dienst, und dort beim
Ausgang ganz normal wieder raus
ins Internet. Und das Problem hast du nicht,
wenn du ein eigenes VPN quasi von Quelle zu Ziel
aufbaust. Baust ein stinknormales VPN,
OpenVPN, WireGuard, was auch immer auf,
zu deinem Freund, da könnt ihr noch so viel
ähm, Copyright geschützte
Porns kopieren oder was auch immer
und das wird keiner merken.
Wo ich natürlich keinen dazu anstiften
will, sowas zu machen.
Crypto AG, wie gesagt, kann ich, kann ich,
sagt mir gar nix, äh,
was ist das?
Skandal um Crypto-ID,
Sicherheitskonferenz.
Oh nee, das, das sieht mir jetzt zu anstrengend
aus, das zu lesen.
Spying Scandal.
Wie denn gespyt?
Ähm,
na klar, ist bei uns, ist bei uns auch
so. Er hat, er hat geschrieben, es ist, es ist schon,
ist aber leider schon 14 Minuten her, weil ich im Chat nicht
hinterhergekommen bin, äh, dass sie
als RZ-Betreiber immer alle Infos rausgeben,
wenn die Polizei kommt, klar. Ähm,
wie gesagt, ich hab ja meine Ausbildung mal pro Weile
gemacht, danach auch eine Weile gearbeitet, das ist da nicht anders.
Wenn du, wenn du innerhalb von Deutschland bist, du hast
gewisse Vorlagen und der ganzen Sache musst du
dich, musst du dich beugen.
Da hast du gar keine Wahl. Ja, manche
Sachen kannst du natürlich, ähm,
nenn ich mal,
nicht vergessen im eigentlichen Sinne,
aber du musst ja nicht überkorrekt sein,
du musst bloß die gesetzlichen Vorgaben einhalten.
Also du musst das, du musst das keine Sekunde
länger aufbewahren, du musst das nicht,
nicht sicherer
speichern, äh, rekonstruierbarer
speichern, als dir das vorgeschrieben ist.
Aber wenn, wenn bei dir
die Polizei, die klingelt ja nicht bei dir,
du kriegst, du kriegst Post,
dann landen wahrscheinlich bei dir beim Chef,
die mit der Auskunft haben wollen, ähm,
da machst du nix.
Das betrifft aber die meisten
VPN-Anbieter,
zumindest nicht, nicht wie das hier in Deutschland
ist, ja. Aber natürlich sind die
VPN-Anbieter auch davon betroffen, je nachdem in welchem
Land sie sitzen, ähm,
wie dort die Regelungen sind.
Deswegen sitzen die ja meistens
sonst wo.
Es gibt bei Tarnkappe einen Bericht, wo sich
einer Betreiber via Chat in eine Polizistin verliebt hat.
Also, das ist,
das ist schon wieder so fail,
dass, dass, ich hoffe,
ich hoffe ja, es hatte wenigstens ein Happy End.
Also hat es
nicht, weil, ich mein, ich bin,
wenn man realistisch ist, hat es das nicht.
Aber wenigstens, wenigstens, das hätte ich ihm
wenigstens gegönnt, ja.
So, ich bin gleich mit dem Chat durch.
Geht, geht, geht
das Stream noch?
Ah, ah, yes.
Nein, ich hab die Crypto-AG nicht in den Schlagzeilen
gelesen. Warum gibt's
kein Ayayay Emote?
Da hab ich bis jetzt
noch nicht dran gedacht.
Du musst mir nicht 50 Milliarden mal schreiben, dass ich
die Crypto-AG googeln soll.
Hier hast du mal was zum Flamen bezüglich
Vodafone.
Das sind ja 50 Minuten, die ich mir jetzt angucken müsste,
dass ich das Flamersky flamen kann.
Wenn das zwischen zwei Leuten ist, kann man's
immer noch zur Not auf dem USB-Stick nutzen, klar.
Aber natürlich, wenn ihr,
wenn man räumlich zusammenwohnt,
kann man auch Sachen auf dem USB-Stick austauschen.
Allerdings dort würde ich's dann
natürlich auf jeden Fall verschlüsselt ablegen
und nicht einfach nur
dem anderen geben.
Hast du schon eine Störungsmeldung im Vodafone?
Nö.
Ich hab eine Störungsmeldung seit
Montag offen hier beim Support.
Und ich hab
heute auch mit einem Techniker telefoniert,
der mir erzählt hat, das muss an meinem
WLAN liegen, was ich nicht verwende.
Ja, Steinex.
Ich hatte jetzt ja
die ganze Zeit auch wenig Probleme.
Hatten wir schon irgendwelche Stream-Probleme
bei Unity Media seit ich da bin?
Ich bin ja auch schon wieder dreivierteljahr da. Eigentlich sehr selten.
Oder?
Warten wir's mal ab.
Bis jetzt läuft's ja.
Also
außer mal die kurzen Aussätze am Anfang.
Jetzt funktioniert's ja.
Ein Rückwegstörer
im Upload-Kanal vorhanden.
Warum sind die...
Warum ist der Support im Unity Media
Forum fähiger
als der Support, mit dem ich heute
telefoniert hab?
Also ich muss sagen,
ich hab bisher immer ziemlich gute Erfahrungen
mit dem Twitter-Support gemacht.
Die sind saumäßig schnell, kümmern sich drum.
Haben sie natürlich selbst keine Ahnung, aber das ist bei
First Level Support ja normal.
Ich würde eigentlich erwarten, wenn das schon bei einem Support-Mitarbeiter
gelandet ist, dann ist das doch
egal, ob das aus einem vom Forum
kommt oder
oder haben die da irgendwie mehrere.
Äh,
DomPC, ähm,
je nachdem, wie du das auf deinem Server gemacht hast,
ist das gar nicht so einfach,
da dranzukommen.
Und du willst ja nicht gerade einen File-Server drauflaufen haben,
der das rausrückt.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das ein Techniker war.
Er hat gesagt, er ist Techniker und hat mir auch
irgendwas über DSL-Mode, äh,
Kabel-Modems und so erzählt.
Ich, ich,
ich warte heute erst nochmal ab. Wenn nicht,
spamm ich die morgen voll.
Dual-Stack vs. reiner IPv4?
Immer Dual-Stack. Wenn du die Chance hast, Dual-Stack.
Es ist bescheuert, nicht jetzt auch
IPv6 zu nehmen. Das ist, äh,
in Zukunft wird es
eh immer schwieriger werden, eine richtige IPv4
Adresse zu bekommen. Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Der Typ, den sie jetzt, ähm,
in den USA,
ich wollte sagen,
verknacken wollen, aber das ist ja noch gar nicht raus,
ähm, der IPv6,
äh, IPv4-Adressen
gescamt hat,
wo ist das denn?
Irgendein Typ hat
es, irgendeine,
irgendeine Firma hat versucht, sich
über, über, ähm, Fake, also
Fake-Firmen, wo ist das denn? Wo hab ich das
letztens gelesen? Aus Beheise?
Ne.
Äh,
ah ja, genau, da, hier, guck mal,
bei Golem war es, genau, hier, eingeklagt,
er weiß, betrug von sich. Genau,
der Typ, der hat quasi verschiedene Firmen gegründet,
und, also unter anderem
auch als, mit Fake-Namen,
obwohl es immer der gleiche war,
und, ähm,
hat dann die Registrierungsstelle quasi
bequatscht, dass er IP-Adressen
kriegt, und da hat er sich halt, äh,
IPv4-Adressen
gescamt, und, ähm,
es ist verboten, man darf mit IPv4-Adressen
nicht handeln, also, ich weiß
nicht, ob es in, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob das
quasi, einfach nur nicht geduldet
ist, oder ob es in Deutschland auch irgendwie verboten
ist, keine Ahnung, ähm, aber
im großen,
großen ganzen Betrachten darf man das eigentlich
nicht, ähm,
also sprich, zum Beispiel
der eine bei mir auf der Arbeit, der
hat früher beim Denik gearbeitet,
und der hatte glaube ich noch
einen custom,
ich glaub, ich glaub einen kompletten
slash16-Blog hatte der noch,
das sind, äh, sind ein paar Adressen, ich weiß nicht,
wo sind, wo sind
die Fisis, die mir aus dem Kopf sagen können, wie viele
Adressen sind slash16,
das wisst ihr doch bestimmt,
big, big brain chat,
ich hab gedacht, jetzt kann der chat, der, der, der chat
mal, mal glänzen,
ja gut, 65.000, 2 hoch 6,
das kommt hin,
das, das kommt hin, ja,
ähm,
so, und irgendwie, irgendwie, der hatte, der hatte,
der hatte quasi noch einen Blog, und den hat er auch
ordnungsgemäß zurückgegeben,
wir hatten zwar ein paar
Leute, die wollten ihn bequatschen, so nach dem Motto,
ey, lass mal gucken, was wir mit den IP-Adressen machen können,
ähm,
aber du darfst nicht, und, äh,
der ist da auch recht gewissenhaft, ich mein, wie
gesagt, du wirst, der hat ja früher bei,
bei der zentralen Stelle, was das geht, gearbeitet,
und, ähm,
der hat das so alles zurückgegeben, ja, also das ist nicht erlaubt,
und,
der hat jetzt halt echt so ein kleines Problem,
mal gucken, was da rauskommt,
bin ich, bin ich mal gespannt,
ähm, ja, wie gesagt, den Stream heute hab ich ja
eigentlich nur angemacht, weil ich testen wollte, ob Unity Media
funktioniert, und bis auf so einen kleinen
Ruckler, ähm,
pah, bei uns auf der Arbeit ist das übrigens witzig,
ähm, da hat sich das Wort
Ruckler auch so, so,
etabliert, ja, also sprich,
die Leute, die nicht sagen wollen Ausfall,
die sagen bei uns aber auf der Arbeit immer
Ruckler, und das hat sich, das ist mittlerweile
zu so einem Unding geworden,
dass die Leute schon unterschiedliche Abwandlungen
von Ruckler erfunden haben, Ruckler,
es hat gehustet,
es stolpert, kleiner Ruckler, großer Ruckler,
äh, holperig,
es war, es war holperig,
das Wort gibt's nicht,
es hat kurz gestottert,
das wird jetzt, Ausfall wird bei uns
mittlerweile in allen nur erdenklichen
Varianten umschrieben,
was, ohne zu sagen Ausfall, ja,
oder, ja, noch schlimmer, Leute,
das, das,
das fieseste Wort bei SNL,
ist
Downtime,
das ist, das Downtime ist wirklich,
da, das muss man vermeiden um alles,
weil, wenn man, wenn man, wenn man sagt Downtime,
da kommen sofort wieder die cleveren BWL
und, und Jura-Leute auf den Start,
Moment, lass mal kurz hier in unseren Vertrag reingucken,
die sagt hier Downtime, Downtime,
nee, nee, nee, nee, guck mal hier,
99,99, das sind 5 Minuten
47 Sekunden und, und,
und 530 Millisekunden,
und dann bam, in your face,
ja, und deswegen wird, das wird vermieden,
ja, also,
bloß nicht Downtime,
ja, und das Lustige ist
auch, wo ich,
könnte ich bei uns immer kaputt lachen, wie wir
uns drum herumdrücken,
und wir, wir machen im Prinzip ja nur
Ausfallstatistiken im Prinzip
nur für uns, also sprich,
die Firma macht das für
sich, um zu wissen, um wissen zu können, wie gut
quasi ihr Service ist, also,
es gibt eigentlich keinen
Grund zu faken bei
diesen Statistiken, es ist
von der Firma
für die Firma, also, die müssen nix
bezahlen oder so, die machen das nur für
sich, weil sie wissen wollen, wie gut ihr, wie gut
ihr Service ist, es gibt
überhaupt keinen Grund, dass wir faken,
weil wenn wir faken,
stellen wir in die Frage, stellen wir ja in Frage
theoretisch, warum wir diese Statistik überhaupt
machen, wenn wir die Statistik von uns
für uns machen, ergibt es überhaupt keinen Sinn
zu faken, aber trotzdem
faken wir unsere Verfügbarkeitsstatistik,
was das Zeug hält,
dass wir da alles rausrechnen,
alles mögliche
rausgerechnet,
was auch toll ist,
jetzt fangen sie neuerdings an,
geplant,
allein schon die Wortkombination
ist geil, geplante
Störungen rauszurechnen, also sprich,
nicht, Wartungsarbeiten rechnen
wir da schon lange raus, weil
die dauern zu lang, die versauen uns jegliche
Statistikzahlen,
wir haben jetzt,
wir sind jetzt bei uns auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
diese Wortschöpfung zu kreieren,
geplante Störungen oder geplanter
Ausfall,
die Kombination aus diesen Wörtern
ist schon irgendwie bescheuert, wenn das
geplant ist, dann ist das ne Wartungsarbeit,
man kanns aber halt nicht verkaufen,
dass man laufend Wartungsarbeiten machen muss,
es ist, es ist unglaublich,
die meisten Leute werdens wahrscheinlich kennen,
die ein bisschen in diesem Umfeld arbeiten,
auch bei nem bisschen größeren Laden, es ist
unglaublich,
ähm, wie sehr
sich dort um, umfasst,
um Formulierung,
um Formulierung und, und,
und so den Scheinwaren gekümmert wird,
und nicht um die eigentlichen Sachen,
geplante Störungen,
was ist denn, bitteschön, jetzt musst du nicht mich fragen,
ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht,
ich hab das nicht aus, ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht,
ne geplante Störung, ich kann dir erklären,
was zum Beispiel bei uns ne geplante Störung ist,
ähm, wenn zum Beispiel,
sagen wir jetzt mal das
VMWert Team, also die für
Virtualisierung Sachen zuständig sind,
wenn die jetzt sagen, wir machen nen
Upgrade von unseren ESX
Clustern auf irgendwie ne neue Version,
dann sagen die, okay, da sollte ja
nix passieren, weil, ähm,
das ist ja von ESX Best
Practice, äh, von VMWert Best Practice, wie wir
das machen, und da passiert nix, wenn die nämlich
sagen würden, äh, wir haben
eine geplante Downtime von
4 Stunden, dann dürften
die nie Updates machen,
und deswegen sagen die, das ist Best Practice
VMWert, und da passiert nix,
normalerweise passiert auch nix,
und wenn in dieser
in diesen Wartungsarbeiten,
die keine
Auswirkung haben, planmäßig,
dann doch was passiert, dann ist
das ne geplante Störung.
Es ist, es ist wie, und wie gesagt,
es ist, es ist unglaublich,
wie sich, wie sich dort, so quasi
im Enterprise, ja, im
Business, wie sich dort an
Formulierungen und Sachen aufgehangen wird, und das
ist der Wahnsinn, also es ist wirklich,
es nimmt auch immer, das nimmt auch immer mehr
zu, aber wir sind eh,
wisst ihr ja Leute, wir sind eh
Enabler in Hyperscale, äh,
Hyperscale Multispeed
Architekturen im Enterprise Umfeld.
Ihr auch, oder? Hoff ich mal.
Oder seid
ihr keine Hyperscale Enabler?
Ich, ich hoffe mal für euch schon.
Weil sonst, sonst dürft ihr
nicht zugucken. Ja, ich sehe Stille,
Stille im Chat, es sind alle, für
selbstverständlich, selbstverständlich
für alle. Der Michael ist
Hyperscaler Disabler,
das, äh,
muss es auch geben, wenn es Enabler gibt.
Oh, du bist Tribe Leader,
der Kommentator. Ah,
das war ich, nee, war ich nicht,
das stimmt nicht, das war ich
nicht, äh,
nur, nur indirekt, weil unser
eigentlicher Tribe Leader immer nicht da war.
Wir, wir waren ja kurzzeitig,
ich hab mich ja mal so in
geistiger Umnachtung für eines
unserer agilen, das hab ich euch ja schon mal erzählt,
für eines unserer agilen Projekte
gemeldet.
Und da waren wir auch in einem,
in einem Tribe vernetzt.
Das, diese, das ist so ein dummes
Bullshit-Gelabere, das
ganze Zeug, äh.
Und am besten sind die Läden,
das, so ein Laden war der
Provider, wo ich früher gearbeitet habe,
die sagen dann, ähm, so nach
dem Motto, wir sind agil, wir machen Scrum.
Und das einzige, was man
macht dort ist, einmal
am Tag zehn Minuten im Kreis
stehen und jeder sagt fünf Wörter.
Das hat mit Scrum absolut
gar nichts, null zu tun.
Das einzige, was man macht ist, man steht im Kreis
und sagt was. Das ist eine stinknormale Besprechung.
Aber man kann sagen, wir machen Scrum.
Und Scrum ist agil.
Und agil ist gut.
So, was machen wir denn jetzt noch?
Serverless KI Hyperscale
Cyber-Enabler.
Ne, das sind zu viele Sachen zusammen.
Da müssen schon normale Sätze rauskommen.
Wie zum Beispiel, haben wir doch
letztens geguckt, Telekom,
der Frontend-Architekt, der war gut.
Oh, oh, den gibt's gar nicht mehr.
Telekom, der Microservice-Architekt,
sehen wir auch nicht.
Telekom, gibt's den Lead-Consultant noch?
Die Telekom
Jobsuche ist weg.
Ok, gucken wir mal.
60329 Frankfurt.
Mal gucken, was die Telekom jetzt zu bieten hat.
Die Telekom sucht nichts mehr, guck mal.
Dabei haben die gestern
erst, doch, machen sie.
Ah, ok, ich war natürlich
nicht weit genug rausgesumt.
Ich weiß, dass die suchen, die posten jeden Tag
auf Twitter.
Und die Telekom, die posten
so ein Cringe auf Twitter.
Telekom erleben
Twitter.
Die posten so ein
Corporate
Cringe-Bullshit-Zeug
da teilweise.
Klemmagalas, großes Kino.
Genau, das ist das, was mich bei der Telekom
ganz, ganz, ganz brennend interessiert.
Smarte IoT-Lösung.
Wenn ich will, dass meine Produktion
ordentlich läuft, dann mach ich das natürlich
ganz bestimmt mit IoT-Lösungen
und natürlich auch mit der Magenta Cloud.
Ne, nicht Magenta Cloud.
Open Telekom
Cloud heißt es ja.
Hast du schon von Magenta DNA der
Telekom-Botschafter gehört?
Manche Sachen tun weh,
wenn man sie liest.
Kennt ihr das? Ihr lest was
und ihr spürt innerlich schon,
dass sich gewisse
Körperteile, Organe
zusammenziehen.
Das geht mir, wenn ich sowas lese wie
Hast du schon von der Magenta DNA
der Telekom-Botschafter gehört?
Da zieht sich bei mir irgendwie so zwischen
zwischen Magen und
und äh
Was ist denn da sonst noch so?
Zwischen Magen und Hals
zieht sich da irgendwas zusammen,
wenn ich sowas lese.
Ich weiß nicht genau, welcher Körperteil
sich bei mir da zusammenzieht, aber
Alter, was ein Blödsinn!
Hast du schon von Magenta DNA
der Telekom-Botschafter gehört?
Stelle für Love, Magenta
und Werkstolz.
Gemeinsam leben wir erfolgreich die Aussage.
Werkstolz, was für eine Vielfalt
sich wenn man ihn teilt. Wir sind dabei.
Telekom-Wall, proud to be Magenta.
Proud to be
Magenta.
Ich weiß
manchmal echt nicht, was mit dem alten Chef
ist, ja. Das leuchtet mir
manchmal nicht ein. Wie sind wir
jetzt eigentlich von
ähm
UDP Package League
äh, nicht Package League, äh
Package Lost, der nicht vorhanden ist,
äh, wie sind wir da jetzt
auf Telekom-Jobs eigentlich gekommen?
Werkstolz.
Ich weiß nicht, komm, wir gucken mal
schnell. Wo waren denn hier die interessanten
Technikstellen?
Hier oben waren die Baby-
Ah, ne, hier, hier. Das war's
für mich. Hier, was für mich.
Das ist, äh, das was ich
auch aktuell mache. Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Alles Müll. Brauchen wir alles.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Ach Gott, geh mal weg.
Als nächstes suchen sie noch Oracle, Leute.
Am besten noch in Kombination.
SAP plus Oracle.
Leute, meine Frage, ähm, ich weiß ja,
ähm, was hast du, äh,
nix Wirksames habe ich gegen SAP.
Ne, gar nix. Ähm, ich weiß ja, dass hier auch
einige dabei sind, die, ähm, da
in dem, in dem Bereich arbeiten. Hat
jemand von euch schon Erfahrung gesammelt mit der
Oracle Cloud? Ich hab jetzt nämlich
heute erfahren, dass das, weil, weil
wahrscheinlich, weil die das bei uns angepriesen haben,
ähm, wussten die, dass Oracle
Cloud auch eine eigene Cloud hat. Hat
jemand Erfahrung von euch mit der Oracle Cloud?
Ich hab heute gehört, von dem einen,
die ist ganz super toll
und der andere sagt, Oracle Cloud soll nicht so gut
sein. Ne.
Okay. Hätte, hätte er sein können.
Free Tier.
Wahrscheinlich läuft Stadia in
Oracle Cloud.
Zutrauen würde ich den mittlerweile, ey.
Stadia ist so am abkacken.
Alibaba Cloud. Die ist, glaube ich,
die ist, also,
ich habe null damit gemacht.
Aber, so wie ich die Chinesen kenne
und so wie ich, wie ich vor allem die Sachen bei
AliExpress und sowas kenne,
wird die Alibaba Cloud
wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut sein für das,
was sie kostet. Die Frage ist halt,
möchte man seine Daten in die China Cloud legen, ja.
So, was haben sie denn sonst noch?
Bachelor of Science
in IT Security. Oh ne, das, da kann ich,
da kann ich mich nicht mithalten.
Oh, guck mal, die, die sind Azubi.
Das ist garantiert ein Azubi.
Weil Fachinformatik, Systemindikation sucht keiner.
Genau, das lernst du in der Ausbildung.
Komm, wie wäre es,
wie wäre es, wenn ihr in den Titel
reinschreiben würdet, dass ihr
einen Auszubildenden sucht und niemand
der Fachinformatik oder Systemindikation gelernt hat?
Ich meine,
es ist im Prinzip, wenn man da schon
eine Weile, ist es klar, weil niemand
sucht eine Stelle
Fachinformatik oder Systemindikation.
Die suchen alle andere Sachen. Aber
es wäre doch schon sinnvoll, wenn man aus dem Job
Titel erkennen könnte, es ist
ein
Azubiplatz, oder? Oder
nicht, und denke ich da zu weit.
Du darfst halt nur mit doppelter und dreifacher
Verschlüsselung in die China-Cloud legen.
Naja, es geht ja bei Cloud-Sachen nicht darum,
dass man einfach den Storage verwendet.
Ja, also im Business-Umfeld
geht es ja darin, dass man seine Anwendung
dort laufen lässt. Und es ist schon
fraglich, wie sicher
das ist, wenn quasi die Anwendung dort läuft,
Daten dort ablegt und die
verschlüsselt sind mit einem Key, der dort auch in der Cloud
liegt. Also,
man muss die Cloud-Plattform, die man
verwendet, der muss man schon so grob vertrauen.
Weil ansonsten kannst du die nicht verwenden.
So, was sucht denn die Telekom heute?
Ein DevOps-Engineer. Also, quasi in
Bonn? Ah, ne, in Frankfurt.
Also, das ist jetzt was, was
mich persönlich quasi ansprechen
sollte. So.
Also, schauen
wir mal. Was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Die Unterstützung und
Etablierung eines DevOps-Mindsets,
zum Beispiel einer Shared Responsibility,
in enger Zusammenarbeit mit den
Architekten dem...
Was?
Das ist bestimmt irgendeine
Business-Geschichte. Das ist bestimmt sowas wie
ITIL, bloß
noch extremer.
Ja, es ist ein
Scaled Agile Framework.
Alles klar.
Scaled Agile
Framework.
Alles klar, oder?
Im Scaled
Agile Framework
Kontext des Hubs.
Ich weiß nicht mal,
von was für einem Hub reden sie denn
überhaupt?
Hub. Nein.
Davon werden sie
definitiv nicht reden.
Wofür ist das E? Framework.
Äh.
Framework.
Framework. Keine Ahnung.
Das muss nicht immer
sinnvoll immer sein.
Spread the Beast abonniert. Ich habe übrigens
gar keinen Sound gehört.
Acht Monate in Folge.
Huge. Dankeschön.
Benutzt ihr auch Azure?
Unter anderem benutzen wir auch Azure.
Bei uns ist so ein bisschen die
ähm, Azure
die Azure Marketing
Leute sind gut dabei.
Okay, also.
Ich habe schon mal das Problem,
dass ich überhaupt nicht verstehe,
ähm,
was ich, was
mir das sagen soll. Aber okay.
Das ist ja meistens nicht so schlimm,
ähm, weil Stellenanzeigen
eh mittlerweile weniger eine
Liste sind,
die man erfüllen muss,
sondern eher so eine,
was übrigens die Entwicklung vielleicht auch beknackt,
aber ist halt mittlerweile so,
eher so eine Wunschliste sind.
Kannst ein paar Sachen von, ist okay.
Zumindest ist es bei uns so.
Bei allen wird es nicht so sein.
Der Ausbau sowie die Administration
unserer DevOps-Infrastruktur, unter anderem
Telekom Workbench.
Haben die auch Tools, die man als
Außenstehender kennt?
Telekom Workbench.
Das, das ja wahrscheinlich nicht.
Telekom Workbench von 2014.
Yes.
Okay, was ist Telekom Workbench?
Müssen wir uns jetzt angucken. Das ist wahrscheinlich wieder
Ah.
Excellent.
Paul.
Ich muss es lauter machen, man hört nichts.
Die Musik!
Die 0815-Markete...
Gibt es
Stockmusik?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das richtige Wort dafür ist.
Das ist aber sowas wie Stockmusik.
Mich würde mal die Wortwahl für die
moderne Ausschreibung für einen Bäcker interessieren.
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich
ähm...
Rohst...
Back- und
äh...
Dings Rohstoff-Zubereitungsexpert.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist wahrscheinlich...
Das ist kein Kickstarter, aber es hört sich genau an wie eine Kickstarter.
Bä...
Aber Bäcker ist doch mindestens mal ein Bäckereifachmann, oder?
The Competition...
Warum pfeifen die jetzt im Hintergrund?
Hyperscale Brotbäcker.
Competition also works on a solution.
Oh, das A-Team, Leute.
The Mission? Paul has to ensure high quality development.
Faster than the competition.
Es wäre auch eine Möglichkeit,
nur mal so eingeworfen,
nicht unbedingt
faster als die Competition zu machen,
sondern im Zeitrahmen
und dafür richtig gut.
Das wäre auch eine Möglichkeit, aber das ist glaube ich
nicht im Scope, wie man so schön sagt.
The first appointment
is a kick-off meeting with teambuilding.
Oh ja!
Da freuen sich alle. Da freuen sich alle drauf.
Ein kick-off meeting
mit teambuilding. Da sind alle scharf drauf.
Alle.
Endlich. Endlich.
Mehr teambuilding-Events.
Wer freut sich nicht, wenn er auf
teambuilding-Events kann?
Da war mal
einer unserer
Managers
übelstinkig
auf uns.
Weil sie hatten irgendein komisches Projekt
fertig. Ist jetzt im Prinzip egal,
was das gewesen ist.
Und da wollte
der auch irgendwelche tollen
Social-Events
zum Abschluss
feiern machen.
Und wir haben alle gesagt,
weißt du was? Ich bin froh, dass der Kram fertig ist.
Lass mich damit in Ruhe.
Ich will einfach nur heimgehen,
wenn das hier fertig ist.
Und dann kam er auf die glorreiche Idee
zu sagen,
Jungs, wir fahren alle zusammen in den
Kletterpark.
Was ist
mit dem Shep im Kopf?
Ich will nicht nach der Arbeit mit den Leuten
in den Kletterpark fahren.
Ich will nicht
Ich will danach, am besten noch
früher als ich sollte,
würde ich gerne heimfahren
und einfach meine Ruhe haben, meinen Stream anmachen
und gut ist.
Und
danach
Wir haben das dann nicht gemacht.
Wie nach der Arbeit. Pflichtveranstaltungsarbeitszeit.
Der Striker hat es schon erahnt.
Und dann war einer, einer von uns,
obwohl wir schon wussten,
das ging voll in die Hose,
ist dann da hingegangen und hat gefragt,
wie das denn ist mit Ausstechen,
weil er kommt ja danach nicht mehr vorbei.
Er fährt ja danach heim, wie er
die Zeiterfassung machen soll.
Und da ist er fast vom Glauben abgefallen,
der Projektmanager-Typ.
So nach dem Motto,
dass es nicht selbstverständlich ist
für uns,
dass wir ganz ohne
vorherige Klärung nicht ganz
selbstverständlich davon ausgehen,
dass wir natürlich das unbezahlt machen.
Und, und, und dafür
Ich mein, die meisten dieser
Veranstaltungen sind tatsächlich unbezahlt.
Was auch ein Grund ist, warum ich da nie hingehe.
Ähm
Aber der ist komplett, der ist komplett
vom Glauben abgefallen und der war danach
richtig stinkig und da hat er
sich gedacht, jetzt wirkt er uns eins rein
und hat gesagt, wir fahren nicht in den Kletterpark.
Und da haben wir natürlich alle gesagt, oh nein.
Wir wollten doch so gerne in den Kletterpark.
So.
Und wo es dann
drauf rausgelaufen ist,
wir sind zu einem Restaurant bei uns
um die Ecke gegangen. Da war ich dann aber auch dabei.
Ähm
Und es gab kostenlos Essen.
All you can eat.
Und kostenlos trinken, inklusive
also Cocktaildrinks und alles.
Ähm
Bis, ich glaub gebucht hatten wir irgendwie
bis 20 Uhr oder so.
Und da waren wir dann irgendwie ab 15 Uhr da und haben irgendwie
war ich zwei Stunden da, hab ordentlich gefuttert,
was genau und bin dann heim. Wunderbar. Perfekt.
Perfekt. Toll.
Das ist super. Da hab ich auch
da hab ich auch, da stech ich gerne aus für.
Ja. Da geht, das ist okay.
Das ist auch nicht so, nicht so gezwungen
dann irgendwie. Da kannst du nicht mit
Der Stream hat geleckt. Ich hab's gesehen, Leute.
Der Stream leckt.
Der Stream leckt. Vodafone?
Vodafone, was ist da los?
Wo?
Ihr? Ja, ich hab das im Blick.
Vodafone, ihr könnt mich nicht debaten.
Sieht so aus, als würde ich's nicht sehen.
Es wär schön, wenn das mal einer klippen könnte.
Kann, kann, kann mal einer klippen?
Dann kann ich das, dann schick ich
das einfach morgen Vodafone.
Nach dem Motto, wo man sieht, dass das auch
aus heiterem Himmel, aus heiterem Himmel ist einfach so.
Na und hier, und hier nochmal
Ich hab vorher Tests gemacht
hier bei mir daheim im Netzwerk.
Da geht nix, da ist nix
da wird nix verloren, wird nix gedroppt.
Ähm
Das ist nur bei der Verbindung zu Twitch und ich hab auch schon verschiedene
Twitch, ähm
Eingangsserver ausprobiert.
Wie gesagt, ich vermute, dass das irgendwo auf dem
Weg ist von Unity Media
beziehungsweise Vodafone zu Twitch.
Dass das gar nicht irgendwie
mit meinem Modem oder so zu tun hat.
Weil warum sollte das heute passen
und morgen nicht? Telekom, der
Vodafone, das ist mir vollkommen egal, weil ich den im Hintergrund
auf hab. Sehr schön.
So, jetzt haben wir das geklippt.
Das hier ist, das ist schon mal
Das muss ich im Auge behalten.
64442,6
Ey, ihr müsst das nicht
posten, ich seh das nachher in der Clip-Übersicht.
Okay, genau, wir wollten uns das Workbench-Video
weiter angucken. Also,
es startet, es startet mit einem
tollen Teambuilding-Event.
...
Er hat die Geburt von seinem Kind verpasst?
Weil er für
ein Projekt gearbeitet hat.
Meinen die das jetzt jetzt wirklich? Egal.
...
Oh, die Bahn.
Und danach sagt ihm sein Chef,
danach sagt ihm sein Chef,
ja Moment, also Arbeiten aus dem Zug,
das ist kein Homeoffice, das kannst du nicht abrechnen.
Aha, passt.
Vielleicht sollte der besser nicht an Computerprojekten
oder an IT-Projekten mitarbeiten,
wenn er das nicht gebacken kriegt.
Baby Rage.
Ah, bestimmt.
Take part in the daily using teleconference
and there is no...
Moment, Moment, Moment, was?
Hat das grad nen Huhn?
Das war ein Huhn, oder?
Darker Z?
Oh je, ISO zertifiziert.
Dann kann das natürlich, dann muss das gut sein.
Ah!
Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich
halbwegs gesagt,
ich habe nicht gecheckt, was das ist.
Das ist sowas, das ist sowas wie Jenkins.
Vermute ich mal.
Das ist sowas wie Jenkins,
bloß, dass noch zusätzlich
ein paar
Features angeflanscht sind.
Das ist quasi ein Jenkins
mit einem Ticketsystem, so im Endeffekt, würde ich sagen.
Ich glaube, das ist, ich glaube, das ist
Moment.
Ha!
Es laggt wieder.
Warte, der Stream läuft doch noch.
Stream läuft.
Läuft noch und wir haben jetzt vollkommen unabhängig von der Bandbreite.
Also ob mit 4, mit 5, mit 2 ist wurscht.
Spackt halt zwischendurch rum.
Machst du noch YouTube?
Ja, prinzipiell schon.
Also ihr müsst mal zwischendurch halt ab und zu mal refreshen.
Ihr seht, ich kann da überhaupt nichts machen dran.
Kann da überhaupt nichts machen.
Oh, jetzt ruckelt bei mir auch das Stream.
Jetzt ruckelt bei mir auch das Stream.
In der Vorschau.
Kompromittiert.
Das war übrigens ein super Gag eben mit der Backup
noch mit Bakula.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch Leute verwenden.
Also ich kenne einen, oh Gott, jetzt geht das gar nicht.
Ich kenne einen, der verwendet es daheim.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch ein Ding ist.
So, jetzt waren wir bei der Gelegenheit.
Machen wir jetzt nochmal einen Test.
Auf meinen UDP, auf meinen
äh, ja, ne.
Da geht nichts verloren. Das scheint alles gut zu sein, ne?
Aber da gehen Sachen verloren.
Also ins Internet gehen Sachen
verloren. Bei mir lokal im Netz
gehen keine Sachen verloren. Aber Leute,
das muss bei mir am WLAN liegen.
Das muss eindeutig
an den doppelten SSIDs liegen.
Unity Media ist einfach
nicht cute genug. Ah, Christine,
Christine ist bestimmt, Christine ist bestimmt,
äh, ziemlich,
ziemlich, äh,
das liegt in einem LoRa-Network.
Bestimmt.
Weil das LoRa-Netzwerk auch
zwischen, weil das auch so schnell ist.
Und zwischen meinem Raspberry funktioniert auch.
Das LoRa-Netzwerk habe ich übrigens gar nicht
in Betrieb aktuell.
Also LoRa-Übertragung
von mir daheim
zum Friedhof.
Ich weiß, jetzt kommen die ersten Leute,
die fragen, Max, warum hast du eine Verbindung
zum Friedhof? Aber da hättet ihr beim
Stream damals einfach dabei sein müssen.
Gut, äh, ja, Telekom,
Telekom-Kunst. Also was soll man denn hier noch machen Schönes?
Jetzt geht's ja mal gerade wieder kurzzeitig.
Ne, Unity Media gibt's nicht mehr.
Aber es ist mir scheißegal, weil ich hab den Vertrag
mit Unity Media gemacht.
Es ist mir vollkommen egal, ob Unity Media oder Vodafone.
Juckt mich null.
Ob das funktioniert. Okay, was soll man sonst noch Schönes machen?
Friedhof mit Glas, okay,
das heißt, ich muss das jetzt, okay, ich erzähl's,
ich erzähl's nochmal kurz.
Ich habe ein, ähm,
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Der ist, was heißt, ich hab,
ich will.
Ich habe es auch schon ausprobiert.
Aber aktuell ist es nicht eingebaut.
Oh, Stream laggt.
Ich seh's auch schon im Vorschaubild.
Aber das hat gerade gelaggt, oder?
Ich, ich seh's, ich seh's genau.
Ich mach mal, ich mach mal kurz wieder runter.
Auf 2 Mbit.
Vielleicht, vielleicht läuft's ja zumindest
halbwegs stabil mit 2 Mbit jetzt.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kriegen wir zumindest noch
den Stream jetzt hin mit, mit, mit, äh, 2 Mbit.
Ja, also mal kurz, kurz, was, was das mit dem Friedhof auf sich hat.
Ich hab auf dem Friedhof ein, ähm,
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
mit nem, ähm,
ESP32 Microcontroller dran.
Nicht mit so nem normalen, mit nem, mit nem, mit ner Low-Power-Variante,
also mit nem Board, was wenig Strom verbraucht und nem Akku.
Und, ähm,
der Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor, das Ding,
wacht zweimal am Tag auf
und schickt mir über Lora
Bodenfeuchtigkeitswerte vom Friedhof nach Hause.
Zweimal am Tag eigentlich.
Zweimal am Tag einfach aus dem Grund, weil es sonst, ähm,
und dann auch nur, wenn die Abweichung größer ist,
als, glaub, 5% oder so.
Zum letzten Mal.
Das Ganze auch nur zweimal, nee, ich glaub 5, 5, 5,
nee, nee, zweimal, zweimal am Tag hatte ich eingestellt.
Ähm, dass die Batterie halt, äh, 2 Jahre hält.
Und dass der Akku 2 Jahre hält.
Ähm, und dann krieg ich aktuelle Bodenfeuchtigkeitswerte
vom Friedhof zu mir heimgeschickt.
Warum?
Naja.
Auf dem Friedhof ist das Grab von meinem Opa und meiner Oma.
Und, ähm, damit ich weiß,
ob ich außerplanmäßig im Sommer hingehen muss
und, und gießen, dass das nicht, äh,
so, so, so eingeht alles,
hab ich da einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Ich fahr da eh hin, ab und zu, aber
im Sommer kann's durchaus sein, dass man, wenn's heiß ist,
mal außer der Reihe hin muss.
Und es nicht mitkriegt.
Und deswegen hab ich dann jetzt, wie gesagt,
er ist grad nicht im Einsatz.
Aber prinzipiell funktioniert er.
Ähm, dann seh ich beispielsweise Bodenfeuchtigkeit,
äh, so quasi kaum, kaum vorhanden.
Und dann weiß ich, ich muss mal wieder vorbeifahren
oder vor, oder hinlaufen.
Ist ja nicht so weit weg von uns.
Ähm, und mal ne Runde gießen.
Hast du auch einen Diebschallsturz für Grabräuber?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab auch noch einen.
Ich hab noch einen für Grabräuber.
Nee.
Aber das ist bis auf die Antenne eingebuddelt.
Das ist in nem IP67,
in ner IP67-Box drinne.
Da guckt nur die Antenne raus.
Das heißt, er müsste wirklich ausbuddeln, den Kram.
Also sprich, das ist ne IP,
das ist ne IP,
so ne kleine,
so ein kleines IP, äh,
67-Gehäuse.
Case.
Oder IP67, oder was?
Ist gar nicht klar.
So ein kleines, so ein kleines Elektronik-Case.
Nee.
IP. Aber IP45
wär nicht dicht, oder?
Okay, Amazon hat keinen Bock, mir, mir Sachen
anzuzeigen.
Ist IP45?
Das heißt doch so, oder?
Bin ich jetzt komplett wirr.
Ich hab da, ja im Prinzip so,
sowas ähnliches, bloß kleiner und in weiß.
Ist das.
Also kleines Plastikgehäuse, da ist da,
da ist der Mikrocontroller drin,
und der Akku drin,
und die, und dann hab ich ein Loch reingemacht,
mit, ähm,
so nem Kegelbohrer,
und, äh, da guckt die Antenne raus.
Und der Sensor ist
quasi dran.
Da hab ich so Versiegelungsspray drüber gemacht,
oben, wo die Elektronikteile sind,
und nen Schrumpfschlauch um
das Kabel, wo's dann zum Controller
reingeht. Das heißt, der, ähm,
der Sensor, der ist auch verbuddelt,
und der funktioniert trotzdem.
Oder? Ne. Ne.
Muss eigentlich, eigentlich funktioniert's.
Wie kommt man auf so ne Idee? Ich meine, okay, für den Garten
die Blumen verschicht, aber noch für den Friedhof muss man erstmal draufkommen.
Ja, selbst.
Massive. Ich bin nur auf die Idee
gekommen, dank
dem Twitch-Chat.
Weil mein, also
generell, der, der, äh,
globale IQ hier zusammen im
Chat, der ist durch die ganzen Subs
sowas von gestiegen.
Da komm ich jetzt auch so wie, auch auf so Ideen.
Huge. Massive IQ.
Vorher wär ich auf so Ideen gar nicht gekommen,
aber seitdem ich, äh, streame
auf Twitch,
und der Chat am Start ist, dann
klappt das. Und wenn ihr dazu beitragen wollt,
dass ich noch mehr so tolle Ideen hab,
ähm,
dann sollte ich euch bei der Gelegenheit
vielleicht mal berichten, was man schönes mit Amazon Prime
machen kann. Wenn ihr nämlich ein
Amazon Prime Account habt, könnt ihr den ganzen
mit Twitch verknüpfen, und könnt
kostenlos einmal im Monat einen Streamer
eurer Wahl mit einem Tier-1-Sub
unterstützen.
Unglaublich, aber wahr.
Beste Überleitung.
Ja, ich hab mir das...
Ich wusste, ich wusste mir das...
Dance Gaming hat die besten. Dance Gaming macht so
geilen Sellout, da abonnieren auch immer
50 auf einen Schlag dann.
Dance Gaming hat die besten Überleitungen
überhaupt, was das angeht.
Exquisite Überleitung.
Ah, yes. Ähm...
Was ist eigentlich aus den Emotes geworden? Alles in Arbeit.
Alles in Arbeit.
Ähm, Dance Gaming hat die beste
Überleitung. Der, der, der, der
bindet das immer so gut, so gut in die
Gameplays ein. So, keine Ahnung, wenn
er irgendein RPG spielt, und, und
dann kommt, dann kommt er zu
irgendeinem Shop, und der, der NPC
sagt irgendwie was, dann sagt er passend
dazu, äh, ja, aber mit Twitch,
mit, mit Twitch Prime wär das Ganze
noch irgendwie viel...
viel besser, oder? Der macht das immer richtig
gut. Es ist eh mein Lieblings-Let's-Player,
hab ich ja schon oft erzählt. Den kann ich mir
auch einfach so angucken, auch wenn's Spiele sind, die
ich überhaupt nicht, nicht spiele,
die ich schon gespielt habe, die mich nicht interessieren.
Dance Gaming kann ich mir immer angucken.
Das ist für mich
einer der wenigen Streamer, dem ich das
na gut, gönnen tu ich's eigentlich
mehr oder weniger allen, aber eines
der Streamer, die ich, wo ich da voll und ganz
ähm, auch, auch
dafür bin, auch gesubbt bin,
und, ähm,
das wirklich super
finde, dass das bei ihm geklappt hat.
Ja? Bei den anderen ist mir das eigentlich,
bei den meisten anderen ist mir das eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Es gibt, es gibt nur ne Handvoll.
Es gibt nur ne Handvoll, wo ich so wirklich sag, ja,
das, das ist gut, das ist Content, der mir gefällt,
dem gönn ich das so richtig hundertprozentig, weil's eben
genau das ist, was ich will. Und da ist Dance Gaming
einer davon. Gibt, gibt noch ein paar andere,
aber der gehört dazu, und
wahrscheinlich nicht von den, von den großen
Mainstream, äh, Streamern guck ich ja
keinen.
XQC hab ich auch ne ganze
Weile geguckt, dass ich, dass ich
XQC nicht mehr gucke, liegt gar nicht
mal an XQC selber.
Ähm, da hat sich
nix großartig geändert. Der Chat,
und ihr wisst, ich bin, ich bin
Fan vom, also,
für mich ist Twitch ohne Twitch Chat
nicht das gleiche. Aber der
XQC Chat,
der ist nicht lustig.
Der XQC Chat ist einfach
sinnloser Spam.
Es gibt andere Channels,
die sind, die sind irgendwie lustig, ja.
Wenn ich, wenn ich mir, keine Ahnung,
bisschen den Hearthstone Assault angucken will,
da guck ich mir Grip an. So.
Wenn ich Grip angucke,
der Chat ist auch Spam, aber der ist nicht
einfach sinnlos.
Der hat 50 Milliardenfach Emotes,
die mit der Sache nix zu tun haben.
Der ist lustig, der Twitch Chat bei Grip.
Aber bei, bei XQC
ist der Chat einfach nur
tot gespammt.
So die Seele rausgespammt aus dem,
aus dem, das Hirn aus dem Chat
gespammt bei XQC.
Deswegen guck ich den nicht mehr.
Weil für mich ist, muss auf Twitch
die, die gute, passende Kombination sein
aus, äh,
Twitch Chat, passende Channel Memes
dabei, ähm, und
der Streamer muss passen.
Was, Grip? Nee.
Ja gebt nur alle eure Qt Points
aus. Da müsst ihr wieder
länger zugucken, dass ihr wieder welche kriegt.
Alle Qt Points
ausgeben, ja. An die
Qt Chat Points, Qt Chat Points
hab ich ja genannt.
Das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Das, das haben wir uns schon mal
angeguckt, NewTeamSpeak.
Das sieht jetzt aus wie Discord, das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt
vor einer Weile. Excellent Spam.
Excellent Chat.
Exquisite Spam. Excellent.
Excellent. So, eigentlich wollte ich
mir die Telekom, wir sind wieder von
Gott zur Welt,
nee, wie sagt man, von, von der Mücke
zum Elefanten, nee, vom, vom tausendste
ins zwanzig Milliardenfachste gekommen
mit irgendwas. Wir sind von
Paket Framedrops
zu Telekom Stellenanzeigen gekommen
und jetzt zu Twitch Chat Spam.
NewTeamSpeak ist
ein Elektron-Ding. Ja, ich weiß, das haben wir uns das letzte
Mal angeguckt. Also, was, was
soll man denn hier noch machen? Also, man, man
baut das aus, administriert die
DevOps-Infrastruktur, unter anderem Workbench.
Wir wissen jetzt ja, Telekom Workbench haben wir
gerade gelernt. Ups.
Telekom Workbench ist so eine Mischung aus
Jenkins und, und,
und, äh, Hira.
Also quasi so eine Mischung aus, zumindest
hab ich das aus dem Werbevideo so, was, RIP?
Excellent, äh,
Service, äh, VodafoneX.
Also, bei mir ist nix F. Ich seh das
in der Vorschau, wenn, also wenn komplett F
ist, dann, äh, seh
ich das.
Also, was macht man, was macht man denn sonst noch
Schönes hier? Die Unterstützung
des Projektteams in der Entwicklung, Qualitätssicherung
und zur Automatisierung von Tests,
der Integration und von
deployments?
Was macht man denn? Was soll man
dann auch alles machen? Die technologische
Basis bildet Java.
Okay, ich will
äh, ja gut, ey, wenn die
Kohle stimmt, würd ich auch Java machen.
Ähm,
Basis bildet Java, OpenShift,
SharePoint,
Hira und Confluence.
Okay.
Warum nicht?
Der Betrieb der Applikation
und des Services in Kooperation mit dem
Plattformbetrieb und der Entwicklung und der Sicherung des Betriebs
durch Monitoring erlösen zu
NFAs, so,
was ist ein NFAs, Leute?
Das sind, äh, äh, äh, äh,
Dings, äh, State Machine Ding, aber das
meinen die nicht damit.
Was sind, was sind NFAs?
Die meinen damit nicht non
finite, finite, bla,
blub, die meinen damit irgendwas anderes.
Den non deterministic finite
automatic, das meinen die damit nicht.
Die meinen damit
irgendwas anderes.
Wir suchen einfach mal NFA BWL.
Da finden wir bestimmt irgendwas.
Ne.
Namibia Football
Association.
Ach so.
Das leuchtet sofort ein.
Striker, ich suche das in Kombination mit BWL,
weil es mir so absolut gar nichts sagt
und die meisten Sachen, die mir so wirklich, in dem Bereich
so wirklich gar nichts sagen, sind entweder
ultrakrasse Buzzwords, wie das meiste hier,
oder irgendwelche BWL-Geschichten.
Ähm, okay, ich kann, kann,
ich weiß nicht, was, was, was das bedeuten soll.
Nicht funktionale Anforderungen.
What?
Ich sag doch BWL-Gedöns.
Knox ist,
Knox kennt sich aus.
Nicht funktionale Anforderungen.
NFAs.
Also das heißt, der Betrieb der Applikation
und der Services in Kooperation
mit dem Plattformbetrieb und den Entwicklerteams
und die Sicherung des Betriebs durch
Monitoring und Analysen zu
nicht-funktionalen Anforderungen
sowie Recovery.
Äh, so wirklich viel schlauer bin ich jetzt aber
auch nicht draus geworden.
Die Konzeption der weiteren Automatisierung von Services und Prozessen,
das ist eigentlich eines der Hauptpunkte,
was man so als
DevOps-Engineer macht.
Die Sätze, die ich lerne, verbessern im Rahmen
agilen Arbeit.
Das muss sich irgendeine,
irgendein so ein Hybrid
aus, ähm,
das hat sich irgendein
Hybrid-Gehirn ausgedacht aus
Personal,
Mitarbeiter und, ähm,
BWL, Mensch.
Aber
anderweitig kommen solche Sätze nicht
zustande.
Du musst so linke Gehirnhälfte Personal sein,
rechte Gehirnhälfte BWL.
Sonst kommst du nicht auf solche
Sätze hier.
Ähm, okay, Ihr Profil.
Jetzt wird's interessant. Mal gucken, ob ich mich da überhaupt
bewerben könnte.
Hallo, dergolive.
Also, Sie überzeugen
durch hohes
Verantwortungsbewusstsein, Zuverlässigkeit,
also, Leute,
ihr kennt meinen Stream und ihr kennt
meinen YouTube Upload-Rhythmus.
Also,
wenn ich nicht durch Zufall, wenn ich nicht die
Zuverlässigkeit in Person bin,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das wird das Top-Plus noch der Solution
wahrscheinlich, was Upload-Rhythmus
und sowas angeht.
Äh, eine schnelle Auffassungsgabe.
Warum kalt ist das?
Also, ich hab keine Ahnung,
wie NFHs herkommt.
Ich kann auch nicht jedes Wort
schon gehört haben. Wahrscheinlich hab ich
sogar schon gehört, aber wieder verdrängt.
Ähm,
okay, also, Zuverlässigkeit,
eine schnelle Auffassungsgabe,
Flexibilität, Belastbarkeit
und überdurchschnittlichem
Engagement
stehen für eine ausgeprägte
Erfahrung im
Eigenverantwortlich-Selbstständigen
Wie oft wollen sie das Ganze noch ausschreiben?
Ähm, und besitzen
eine starke Bereitschaft zur
Teamarbeit.
Ah, yes.
Ähm, weiterhin verfügen sie,
wie wär's denn mal, wenn ihr mich fragen würdet,
ob ich technisch ein bisschen was kann? Wär vielleicht auch nicht ganz
uninteressant. Ein abgeschlossenes
Studium der Informatik, Wirtschaftsinformatik oder
Be-
Okay, die suchen definitiv nicht mich.
Mit technischem Schwerpunkt oder eine
vergleichbare Berufsausbildung, Mehrwegeberufsarbeit
in agilen Softwareentwicklungsprojekten
Java,
Java Enterprise,
Python und möchten ihren Beitrag zur
Cloud-
Cloudifizierung
äh, ich hab dafür leider
kein passendes Emote.
Ich hab kein Emote, was mein
aktuelle Gefühlslage ausdrücken
könnte,
wie ich meinen Beitrag zur Cloudifizierung
leisten möchte.
Ähm,
okay, gute Kenntnisse und
praktische Erfahrungen in der Umsetzung von
DevOps und Continuous Integration,
Continuous Delivery, Automatisierung
und mit zugehörigen Entwicklungstools
zum Beispiel OpenShift,
OpenShift,
Kira, Confluence,
GitLab,
Aha, für GitLab.
Find ich gut. Und Jenkins.
Und ja, Leute,
ich weiß, jetzt kommen wieder alle um die Ecke
und sagen, das heißt aber Jira.
Nein, das heißt Hira.
Das sagt der Hersteller sogar selbst, dass das
Hira heißt. Die suchen
Stonks, Leute. Meinst du? Klingt
ein bisschen so. Ähm,
ausgeprägte Fachkenntnisse,
fundierte Erfahrungen als DevOps-Engineer in der
Automatisierung von
definierten Services, Prozessen
und oder Betriebsmodelle.
Das ist, wisst ihr, was diese
Stellungnahme ist? Die ist unglaublich, um den
heißen Brei drumherum
geredet.
Ähm, Installations-
und Konfigurationserfahrung für komplexe
Softwareprodukte und
Services und
und haben Spaß
an der Unterstützung der
Teammitglieder während der Fehleranalyse bis zur
Fehlerbeseitigung. Außerdem arbeiten
sie gerne in internationalen Teams
nach agilen Methoden,
Scrum, Kanban,
SAFE.
Ähm, ich hab schon wieder vergessen, was es war.
Agile, äh,
Scalable Agile Framework
und
haben Spaß daran, komplexe Sachverhalte
zu analysieren und in funktionierenden
Software umzusetzen.
Verhandlungssichere Deutsch- und fließende Englischkenntnisse
mindestens CEF.
Das ist, damit meinen sie wahrscheinlich
nicht Chromium Embedded, vermute ich
mal. Oh, das, das
würde mich ja interessieren, ob die den Gag verstehen würden.
Wenn man, wenn man das in die, das
würde das verstehen die Typen nicht, die die Bewerbung
lesen. Wenn man
sagt, äh, äh, Embedded Chromium Erfahrungen
sind vorhanden auf Level C1.
Das checken, das checken, das kapieren
die nicht. Ähm, sowie Reisebereitschaft
national, gut.
Eigentlich was, was mich vom
Titel angesprochen hat, aber vom Inhalt her
absolut gar nicht.
Ich glaube, dazu fehlt mir
einfach die Magenta DNA.
So
wie Werkstolz und Love Magenta.
Das ist einfach nicht ausgeprägt
genug bei mir dafür.
Vor allem Werkstolz finde ich toll.
So, jetzt haben wir mal schön
abgelästert über Telekom, über alles, über alles
haben wir schön abgelästert.
Bist du nicht proud
to be IT? Ne, ich bin proud,
ich bin proud to be Magenta.
Das ist so, ich muss
mir das Ding bookmarken, das ist so
krasser Cringe, dieses, dieses Command, äh.
Ja, Leute, ähm.
Es ist 21.50 Uhr.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine
Ahnung, wie ich zwei Stunden
rumgebracht habe.
Ich, wir haben im Stream nichts gemacht,
außer, außer sich ein bisschen, äh,
zu lästern über alles Mögliche.
Ähm, ich wollte mir eigentlich noch mit euch,
habe ich mir heute überlegt, wir können uns mal wieder die aktuellen
GitHub Trends angucken, ob es da
irgendwas Spannendes gibt. Weil der eigentliche
Ziel von diesem Stream war ja,
zu gucken, ob
es, was nicht
der Fall ist, ob es
Vodafone, beziehungsweise Unity Media
wieder hinbekommen hat.
Dass es,
ordentlich läuft.
Schauen wir mal, was gerade so
trendet.
Wir haben noch 10 Minuten Zeit, können wir mal schnell drüber gucken.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass wieder nur chinesische
Repos trenden, wie das letzte Mal.
Das letzte Mal war heftig, oder?
Haben wir GitHub geguckt und irgendwie
70% waren Repos,
wo wir noch nicht mal den
Namen der, der Anwendung lesen konnten.
True.
Lulwe.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Der Microsoft Application
Inspector.
Oh, da fällt mir ein, jetzt wo
ich das sehe, was wir ja auch im Stream machen
wollten, ist noch, wir wollten uns mal
die Bundes, der Bundes
Nachrichtendienst, die
Bundes Nachrichtendienst
Reverse Engineer Challenge angucken.
Wobei ich ja da
so das doofe Gefühl habe,
dass ich das,
dass ich das nicht gut erklären kann und
am schlimmsten auch wahrscheinlich komplett verkacke.
Also je nachdem, wie schwierig das ist.
Weil ich bin kein großer
Hackermann, was das angeht, in der Richtung.
Da fehlt mir einfach das
Interesse und dadurch die Übung.
Und die Kenntnis dazu, ja.
Also, ähm,
ich weiß nicht, wie schwer das ist.
Ich weiß nicht, wie schwer das ist, ja.
Also ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Assembler angucken können wir uns.
Vielleicht das andere, andere irgendwie
decompilen und bisschen, ich weiß nicht,
wie schwer es, wie schwer es ist.
Kann man sich bei denen durch Hacken
bewerben, ja. Also konnte man mal.
Das ist, das ist, das ist von 2016.
Eine Lizenz zum Q-Chat.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie schwer das ist.
Ich guck mir ja manchmal ganz gerne Videos
an, wo Leute irgendwelche
Capture the Flag Challenges machen.
Ich verstehe das
zum größten Teil, was sie da erzählen, aber
ich würde da selbst
nicht drauf kommen.
Mir fehlt da einfach die Übung und auch das Interesse
an diesem Themenbereich. Das ist nicht so
das, was mich großartig interessiert.
Ähm,
aber wir gucken uns das auf jeden Fall mal an.
Und ich hoffe, dass wir nicht schon
bei der ersten Challenge verkacken werden.
Ja.
Es ist, es ist Jahre her, wo ich
zuletzt mal einen, einen Debugger,
also, kein Debugger, einen, ähm,
wie nennt man das eigentlich?
Diese Kategorie
Software, hier, äh, Disassembler, genau.
Wo ich den Disassembler
verwendet hab, ähm,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie man den gerade überhaupt bedient.
Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das,
ob man, ob, ob sie,
ja doch, die Software gibt's anscheinend noch.
Das, das ist wirklich Big Brain,
Leute.
Das ist wirklich absolut huge,
huge brain Software, ja.
Ah, yes, Disassembler Code.
Ähm,
Gitra, ja, das hab ich auch schon gehört, das ist das
vom FBI, ne, oder von, von der,
ne, nicht vom FBI, vom, vom,
von der NSA, von der CIA,
von irgendeinem Geheimdienst
ist, ist das, genau.
Gitra.
NSA.
Genau das da.
Gitra Tutorial, okay.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Will doch mal gucken.
Ah, Excellent Assembler, so
muss das sein.
Huge. Ach, guck mal, er hatte schon das
decompilte.
Das Assembler
dekompiliert, oh ja,
äh, ich hoffe, ich hoffe,
die Challenge wird sich nicht, nicht
so sehr mit sowas beschäftigen,
weil da bin ich nun wirklich nicht der Pro.
Aber gucken wir uns mal an.
Gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns in einem der nächsten Streams mal an.
Ähm,
ich mein, ich könnt hier auch bescheißen, ja.
Ich könnte einfach mal im Internet
suchen davor, mir die Lösung
angucken,
und, ähm, dann setz ich mich im
Stream hin und sag, ah, okay,
ach ja, hier, äh,
hier, Move, äh, Move1,
EAX nach, ähm,
ah, diese Adresse, ah,
yes, hier, hier, äh,
AddJump nach, verstehe, ah,
Assembler, ganz klar, was hier passiert, ist
das Ausschlaggebende.
Ja.
Könnte ich natürlich mal, ich könnte, ich könnte natürlich bescheißen.
Ich könnte mir das vorher einfach, die vor allem vorher schon
angucken.
Und dann tu ich so, als hab ich keine
Ahnung. Ich mein, ist ja
heutzutage nicht mehr verwerflich, sowas
zu machen.
Es gibt Leute, die machen
Videos darüber, dass ihre Freundin
gestorben ist,
obwohl sie noch lebt.
Das heißt, die, die,
die moralischen Ansprüche,
was Content, äh,
Creator so haben
heutzutage, die sind, die sind schon
so weit unten, die kann
man eigentlich als normaler Mensch gar nicht
mehr unterbieten. Das heißt, dann
ist das auch vollkommen okay.
Warum nennt man so
was Antwortbogen? Ja, weil's der Bundesnachrichtendienst
ist. Die machen natürlich ihre Dateinamen
auf Deutsch. Ah, hier ist die Seite
vom...
Ah, doch, geht.
Oh, Leute.
F
Exquisite Unity Media.
Ganz toll.
Ich, ich, ich mecker morgen nochmal ein bisschen auf
Twitter rum, heut Abend hab ich keinen Bock mehr.
Ähm, okay.
Wir gucken jetzt nochmal schnell über die Trending-Repos
drüber. Wir haben maximal noch
10 Minuten Zeit.
Dann muss ich pennen, weil morgen wieder 5.45 Uhr aufstehen.
Und, ähm,
dann geh ich wieder
mit Haftbefehl zum Mexikaner-Essen.
Und am Wochenende
bin schon wieder
länger on. So.
Deno. Das wollte ich auch mal
on stream ausprobieren. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher,
äh,
erstens, inwieweit, inwieweit das interessant
ist und ich bin mir noch viel weniger
sicher, warum's,
warum's das überhaupt gibt.
Das ist von den Node.js
Leuten, also
von den ursprünglichen Node.js
Gründern quasi,
ne neue
JavaScript Runtime.
Basiert auch auf V8, ist im Prinzip
alles das gleiche, aber ne neue
JavaScript Runtime mit
TypeScript Support innen drinne und, und
äh, äh, Rust, äh,
Rust, ähm,
V8 Bindings. Irgendwie
sowas, ja. Ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher, was der Vorteil davon ist.
Weil ich mein, ein Riesenvorteil von
Node.js ist nun mal die,
die weite Verbreitung und dass es 30 Milliarden
Pakete gibt. Ich weiß nicht,
wozu man ne
JavaScript Runtime braucht,
wenn man keine fertigen
Pakete verwenden kann, weil eines der Riesenvorteile
von JavaScript ist ja nur gerade mal,
dass es eben so viele fertige Pakete gibt.
Was auch immer.
Das gucken wir uns vielleicht irgendwann
mal in dem Stream nochmal ausführlich an, was da
jetzt das Tolle dran ist, weil es hat
wahnsinnig viele Sterne in letzter Zeit gekriegt. Das ist quasi,
du hast jedes Mal bei den Repos drinnen
die Trenden und ich hab mir auch kurz mal
ne, boah, F.
Oh.
Oh je. War kurz auf 0, äh.
Geht's mir doch.
Jetzt haben wir wieder ein super, super
grandioser, äh, lagfreier Stream
heute. Dann gibt's als nächstes
ein Programm, mit dem man die, die, die
China Firewall umgeben kann.
Unity Media will, dass ich off gehe.
Leute, ich sag's, die wollen,
die wollen, dass ich, dass ich off gehe.
Der Eichler, 6 Monate, dankeschön.
Huge Brand Sub. Ups.
Voll, vorher falschen
Knopf gedrückt.
Ne, ist gar kein Prime. Richtig echter.
Wahnsinn.
6 Monate. Huge.
Huge Sub Badge.
Wollte ich sagen, aber immer noch keine
Sub Badges. Äh, kannst du einschätzen,
wie lange es dauert, Java
für Diagramme in Google oder D3
zu lernen?
D3 ist doch nicht Java, D3 ist doch
JavaScript.
Oder nicht? Ich kenn bloß D3, ich kenn bloß
das für, für, die JavaScript.
Gibt es D3 auch für Java?
Ähm, es kommt
drauf an, wie, wie sehr du dich schon auskennst.
Es ist immer, es ist immer
schwierig, ne komplett neue
Programmiersprache zu lernen
und zusätzlich quasi noch Sachen
zu lernen, die dann in dieser Programmiersprache
ähm, geschrieben sind.
Ja, also wenn man eine Sache
macht, ist man meistens schon brainmäßig
genug ausgelastet. Ach,
JavaScript.
Praktisch null.
JavaScript hat den
großen Vorteil, dass du halt ziemlich schnell
praktisch im Browser immer siehst,
was passiert. Ähm,
hast du schon Programmiervorerfahrung
in anderen Sprachen oder fängst du
generell bei null mit dem Programmieren an?
Das ist eigentlich das Entscheidende.
In HTML ein bisschen.
Okay, das heißt, du hast keinerlei Programmiererfahrung.
Ähm,
dann, gut, dann kommt's
natürlich auf dich an, wie viel Zeit
du reinstellst, wie viel Hingabe
du der ganzen Sache widmest, aber bis du da
was ordentliches, was ordentliches
zusammenkriegst, wenn du schon komplett anfängst,
ja, es ist immer ein bisschen von
Person zu Person unterschiedlich. Ich würd mal sagen,
so einen Monat,
so einen Monat musst du schon mal mit rechnen,
dass du, dass da
was irgendwie halbwegs anschaubares
rauskommt. Da bist du jetzt natürlich
kein Ultra-Bro oder so,
ähm,
aber ich würd mal sagen, in einem Monat
so von null zu ein bisschen
JavaScript mit, mit ordentlichen
Graphen und Logik
ist, ist drinne.
Vielleicht bist du auch das Naturtalent
und guckst dir ein paar Tutorials an und kannst
das dann soweit abändern für die Sachen, die du brauchst
und brauchst dann nur eine Woche für.
Aber, je nachdem, wie komplex das ist,
was du machen willst, also einen Monat würd ich da schon
mal einplanen, aber du hast ja auch, oh fuck,
was ist jetzt los, ah, es ist voller
Abkacken, jetzt wird's rot hier.
Aber du hast ja auch was von.
Seit wann gehört Unity Media zu Vodafone?
Seit vorgestern, also schon länger, aber seit vorgestern
ist das jetzt ganz offiziell so.
Okay, Leute, gucken wir uns,
gucken wir uns nächstes Mal die, ähm,
die Trending-Repos
an, oder so, oh, da wollen wir,
komm, komm, wir gucken, wir gucken schnell Trending-Repos.
Scheiß drauf, ob's Ding ist, ich wollt mir jetzt einfach angucken,
was es gibt. Äh, irgendwas für die
Firewall in China,
äh, irgendwelche Machine Learning
Dinger, die mich nicht jucken, ne Game Engine,
äh, Standard-
Algorithmen und Datenstrukturen in Java,
okay, wenn man, wenn man,
wenn man's,
auch, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll, Terraform,
das ist irgend so ne Provisioning, äh,
äh, Serveraufbau, ähm,
wie nennt man das,
was sagen sie denn, selbst,
äh, irgendeine Kubernetes-Cloud-Geschichte
auf jeden Fall.
Wie, wie ist, wie ist das hier, äh,
Infrastructure as Code oder so was
nennen sie sich, glaub ich selber.
You don't know JavaScript,
das ist in der Tat so.
Google Research,
Job, Job, das kann ich nur empfehlen,
das einzige Elektron-Programm,
was ich verwende, Discord
war außen vor, Discord ist Discord,
da kommst du eh nicht dran vorbei.
Das einzige Elektron-Programm, was ich verwende,
also Notizprogramm,
äh, nen, nen,
Task- Notizprogramm
mit, äh, Erinnerungs- und Kalender-
Funktion,
was
komplett Cross-Platform ist, Windows, Linux,
Mac, Android, IOS.
Gibt nichts Vergleichbares,
ähm, vor allem nicht Open Source,
und zum Selbst-Hosten, das kann ich nur empfehlen,
das Ding, das ist wirklich gut.
Open Pilot, Open Source Driving Agent,
äh.
Unser Azubi, ne,
hab ich ja letztens im Stream, im Stream
erzählt, dass wir nen Azubi haben.
Oh Gott, wie das wieder scheiß
abkackt.
Unity Media, come on,
please, brah, come on,
brah, was ist hier los?
Eieieiei.
Ähm, zumindest, weil ich kann sagen,
unser Azubi, ne, ich hab ja letztens im Stream erzählt,
dass, dass ich jetzt, dass mal wieder einer
bei uns am Start ist, der hat jetzt voll Blut
geleckt, der hat, der hat, der hat mir heute,
ne, gestern erzählt, dass er jetzt
nen Raspberry Zero in sein Auto einbauen
will mit Touchscreen.
Mach einfach, mach mal,
mach mal. Ähm,
wie heißt das, das hier, das hier ist das Notizding.
Das ist wirklich sehr praktisch.
Ähm,
hab,
ähm,
das ist diese
neue Geschichte von Github.
Bessere Github-Interaktion
per Kommandozeile. Hab ich noch nicht
ausprobiert. Ich weiß nicht,
was es für tolle Sachen
machen kann.
Weiß nicht, was es ist, weiß nicht, was es ist.
LLVM, gut.
Compilergedöns.
App-IDs. Oh, das Repo muss ich
mir merken. Wir krieg-, es gibt so
viele Fragen hier immer im Stream.
Ähm, was ist ne gute
Anwendung zum Üben?
Die Musik stört hart, wenn die so rum, äh,
kann doch n-, ich kann
nix machen. Ich, ich
hab keinen Einfluss drauf. Ich kann die Musik ausmachen.
Gucken wir jetzt noch schnell, bis wir hier durch sind.
Barry.
Barry?
Active Development Trunk vor Jahren 2.
Warum heißt das Barry?
Und warum zum Geil müssen die schon wieder
was neu auflegen?
Ja, das ist, das ist so typisch
JavaScript-Ökosystem, ne?
Zuerst gibt's NPM,
alle sind super happy mit NPM,
bis, bis, bis auf ein paar,
die machen Jahren, und jetzt ist das
nicht genug, jetzt machen sie Barry.
Das ist so diese typische JavaScript-Geschichte,
jeden Tag 50.000 neue
Libraries, die das
machen, was andere 50.000 Libraries ja
schon machen. Ah, yes, JavaScript.
How to make more money.
Das ist, äh,
Easy Chen, ja.
Hätt mich auch interessiert, aber
wenn's eh nicht funktioniert außerhalb von China.
Na gut, Leute, ich hoffe,
Unity Media beziehungsweise
Vodafone kriegt ihren Scheiß zusammen,
weil über
2 Stunden Stream,
2 Stunden 15 Stream,
6,5%
Frametrops
ist hart.
Wir sehen uns. Bis die Tage.
Macht's gut. See you.